what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
[Applause]
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys drop a like and leave
a comment and we are just starting
member channel memberships so if you
guys want to keep staying in the live
chat sign up for a membership because
that is going away ish why should we
take it away like two weeks
give them two weeks two weeks all right
two weeks we're taking away um
the the chat so it's only gonna be
members only so
okay guys we have a lot of special
guests today why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and where the people
can find you
okay so you can start troy francis 48
years young
and you can find me at
realtroyfrances.com my youtube channel
is called uh troy francis so at
realtruckfrancis.com is for instagram
and uh twitter and so on my my website
is realtroyfrance.com also and i am
single
[Laughter]
troy's a vampire
because he does not look his age yeah
thank you very much i'm still in cooper
i am 35 years old
it's complicated
and
you can find you can find my stuff at
sterlingcooper.com stealing spelled
s-t-i-r-l-i-n-g
i'm
an award-winning porn star a former
high-class male companion and now i
teach dudes uh sex advice on the
internet
okay
i didn't know that before you sat down
did you
hi i'm chrisley i'm almost 31 you can
find me on instagram at christiclarman
and yeah
relationships. oh sorry um
i want to say single
you want to say so are you you're not
sure
some some man's heart just broke
and she's sitting between me and you
started yeah that's why i'm saying
singles
yeah it's tough
it's a great start
okay so
my name is justin waller i have a
youtube channel i have uh some normal
businesses as well you can find me on
youtube jaywaller you can find me on
instagram jwaller7 you can find me on
twitter waller7j and i have an email
list you should sign up for it
immediately
uh i actually am heartbroken right now
because i thought that sterling and i
were in a relationship but apparently
it's complicated
and i think that's it oh yeah that's it
okay i'm nana reverend um i'm married
and you can find me at your aunties
could never i have a podcast it's called
your aunties could never and it's your
auntie's could never on instagram and on
youtube as well and it's called aunties
could on twitter
okay and i'm shade i'm 41 and i'm single
i'm i'm also on your aunties could never
so you can find me there too
okay guys so thank you all for coming
today's topic is
ladies
let your man cheat
um so i have a question for the women on
the panel
which by the way is [ __ ] because me
and sterling didn't know that that's
what the title was we got set up
totally set up
um so i want to know have you guys ever
been cheated on and did you take him
back
yes
and yes okay
um
yes
and no
i didn't take him back
but i haven't been cheated on that i
know of in my marriage
um
yes
and
different times different results so
sometimes i have but most times no i
haven't okay
so a second question for the girls if
there was a guy that was taking care of
your bills 100
and you you were taking let's say you
get 10k a month
and you find out that he cheated
but it was it was just just a hoe you
know nothing nothing not in love just
just just sex
would you look the other way
you know what it really depends how the
information had come to me
um
and the level of shame involved but i
would say
if i found out myself like through texas
and or emails or whatever or heard
and nobody else really knew i would
probably just pass it off
i would be fine it as long as nobody
else knew yeah it would depend on the
level of shame like if i was like a
celebrity and it came out and it was on
all the blogs it's not happening do you
want to
ask yeah go ahead yeah like that so like
it's
you relate that the
the transgression
how bad it is to how much it impacts you
publicly yeah right so for example if
if it was a case of like
oh he just hooked up with this random
girl in a bar
no one really knew about it he might
have confessed it to you in private
you could get over that it's the level
of stupidity that would be involved in
the transgression because it's like if
they have to try and justify
this to your girlfriends your family to
myself and my prior to my ego right yeah
right but if it's not out there in
public
i can justify then you can justify it
but a lot of you which is yeah why i
would argue that it's not justifying it
to yourself it's the level of
embarrassment he put you through
yeah embarrassing you in front of your
friends yeah but not really to yourself
because you without anybody finding out
would stay
because my ego would be able to put that
into check yeah yeah but the
transgression world sees the site you
get cheated on
i mean sorry the the transgression is
the same it's it's it's not worse just
because more people know about it so
it's really interesting that you
uh it shows i think it's a really
interesting place to start on this
actually i think it shows
i mean my take on this and you know
forgive me if i'm wrong but women sort
of that they are very concerned with the
sort of the appearances of things
and that's almost worse than the actual
pnv side of things if you see what i
mean yeah i agree yeah i think that's
actually an extremely mature
answer to that question
honestly that is i did not i didn't
expect anyone to say that on this
podcast i think that's because it's
interesting yeah i'm sorry to cut you
off but i think that's because all women
know
on a core level that
men are like this yeah and if he's
taking care of you fully you're not
going to walk out the door on them
whereas like she said sometimes she
leaves sometimes she doesn't
sometimes a woman will just use it as an
excuse to leave because we know all men
are going to generally do it
if they can man does it you're not going
to leave him because what are you going
to do leave him for a man you love less
than him
that could be that what do you think
what do you think um
i i'm just gonna cheat on you anyway by
the way say it again he's the second guy
that you leave for that you love less he
will cheat on you if you can't a
possibility it's a possibility i think
but i just don't know whether it's
innately
a man's
disposition that he's gonna necessarily
do that and whether it's like i weigh up
whether it's like
innate or is it society that makes it
all right and allows it and continuously
oh it's definitely not society well i'll
tell you it's it's
women
women of men have different mating
strategies so so men like they want to
spread their same women want to get the
highest value guy possible to reproduce
with so men are more likely to cheat
because like they're trying actually
statistically they're not more likely to
cheat but i would say if men are given
the option to cheat they're more likely
to do it yeah i would say it is innate
in man and i would say the reason
perhaps
more men don't cheat the reason that
every single man on the planet doesn't
choose is partly because of society and
partly because of their lack of options
right i think most guys stops them i
think i think i think a lot of guys you
know who are sort of you know married
guys say in the uk whatever
um
who are sort of living in fairly
mainstream kind of lifestyle they're
probably the key reason they're not
cheating is because they don't have the
opportunity or they don't feel that they
have the opportunity and let's say this
is that a man's inability to cheat
should never be mistaken for loyalty
because it's not not the same thing it's
not the same it's totally different well
but how would you know the difference
between a guy that's just cheating to
cheat because like that's his urge and a
guy that's like
in love with his side chick because i i
think
he stops falling in love with you
because here's the problem we need to
redefine the word cheat okay because
because men
we're really we're really using the
wrong word here because men if given the
opportunity of having the abundance
they're going to sleep with other women
cheating is either emotional
or resources and most importantly taking
resources away from the woman that he is
supposed to love and giving it to some
ho
that's when a woman really should leave
because any man given the option
is going to do it and a lot of times a
woman a man will trade sexual
exclusivity because he's not the guy
that can get it regardless
i know so can i just say that not all
women that men cheat with are hoes like
that's exactly
the truth and i just don't like it like
they're being categorized by that
because it's like dehumanizes them and
it's like they're people too so it might
be a woman it might be a woman he also
falls in love with it might be very much
it might be or just might be casual it
doesn't mean that she's less
than she might not be the connotation of
that word i don't know i feel like if
you're if you're knowingly being a side
piece you're kind of a hoe but something
yeah
i mean i'm not talking okay yeah but
we're talking you're giving like the
situation where she doesn't know i'm
talking about when she knows now like
that's what i think if you if you if you
just sort of like take a helicopter view
you know you you you kind of just just
look at it from from the highest angle
um
everybody is just acting out in their in
their sexual interests right so men are
acting out in their sort of you know
their sexual interest in you know for
the best thing sort of biological or
medium evo biological level for them and
women are doing the same thing so yeah
you're corrected away i mean we
shouldn't really make a moral judgment
about it because people are just doing
what they do right right you know what i
would also add to that
first of all i think you're completely
right
you're right however i'm going to
continue to use a word because let me
tell you why
if i care about no seriously go and go
if i care about my main girl
i am going to ver like from a verbage
standpoint
ho in my mind especially when i'm
talking to her baby's just a hoe yeah
because what she she a woman that's
smart enough to know
to protect her is to protect the queen
and
and if she's smart enough to realize how
the world actually works what she what
she's going to do is she's going to
allow you to trade out what used to be
sexual exclusivity for position yeah and
that means that you're there's hoes but
you're never going to leave the queen
yeah but all that tells me is it's just
a kind of clever way to use language to
manipulate the woman in order to keep
her to stay it's not just language it's
commitment it's love speaking to the mic
yeah so but yeah it's just it's just a
manipulation it's just like used like
making women
pitting them herself against each other
basically but she gets she gets more
than she gets more than the verbage have
you ever made the argument that
a a man doesn't love a woman if he
sleeps with another woman
i've heard it right do you believe it no
i i i
i just think that men can pretty much do
what they want so i just don't know i
realize it's the men we pick so i feel
like as when we have to take
accountability for the men we pick so if
you pick a guy that's in that top like
five percent one percent whatever it is
like
you can't be shocked when you get
cheated on like if you pick an nba
player like you're gonna get cheated on
and also as well it's not it's i
wouldn't say nba i wouldn't say it's a
manipulation though there's not many in
london i wouldn't say it's manipulation
in the sense that the the woman you know
still has the agency to walk away if she
wants she doesn't have to you know he
can say their hoes and you're the queen
and she can say well i don't i don't
accept that phrase so i got to walk away
totally i mean nobody's stopping her
from doing that so in that sense it's
not manipulative it's just you know she
is manipulative because there's a
picture she has the freedom
and i want this girl don't try and be
like oh you're the main but somebody
does love her don't do a pyramid scheme
literally just saying
but i like you as well you you are
fulfilling me sixty percent
and this one gives me twenty and this
one gives me ten and i've got two others
over there and they give me five each
and then let her decide but the reality
is the reality is for a guy there
usually is one that you like more than
the other yeah
don't feel like you're the queen and
this one's just a hoe just be honest and
be like look i want to be with all of
these people are you down or are you not
i think i think that is honestly that is
honest so that's you just said it all
yeah you're the queen
all those women are hoes
no but that is truly honest
okay are you having do you have a
problem with the words she just doesn't
like the language i think i think that
like just don't try and degrade them and
be like yeah
just literally
i like this girl yeah and i like to see
her on a tuesday on a wednesday and i
like to see this one on a
friday me propose something what if what
if instead of him saying queens and hoes
he said queens and princesses
that's degrading to those princesses
personally
that's a bit dodgy like so i'm the queen
and then you have princesses our kids
should be the princesses
that's where i would go with that but
just be honest
and beauties
yeah just say i've got other women and
then we can decide just be honest
you know i don't nameless amorphous glo
let me get this right um
you're affected by the wording so if
someone was to change the wording they'd
be able to manipulate you into no no
just be honest the wording has
connotations like really negative
connotations and most times when people
have actual marital relationship sex and
what that is it's not necessarily a
woman who is do you know what i mean
like there's anything wrong with her
yeah what he has like you know you know
what you know what i think i i think the
reason why
sorry to cut you off um
i think the reason why a lot of men will
use this different kind of verbage
is
from their uh to to get rid of
societal guilt
because men and you you mentioned this
before
uh
you said something something along the
lines of you know do you think society
has this sort of impression on men i
think men are
under a lot more pressure to feel guilt
for
quote-unquote cheating okay than women
are i think they have
programmed from day one
from things let's say from obviously
religious things equivalent of women
cheating you say men
have more like feeling more guilt
oh yes i think the average man the
average man like
the men on this panel are kind of an
exception to this rule
but i think the average man
would feel a tremendous amount of guilt
at even thinking
about sleeping with another woman if he
had a woman he loves with he's in love
with so when you say all men cheat
though like but you're also saying that
they feel a tremendous amount of guilt
so what you're saying is they cheat and
they just feel it i don't i'm not saying
they all cheat
i'm saying propensity to yeah they want
to they have the desire there's a desire
the urge it's in them it's
that lust right men there's one thing
that no woman can give a man
unfortunately
and that one thing is variety
we're biologically programmed to want
variety and as beautiful as you are as
amazing as you are as a as good of a
mother as you want to be the prettiest
woman the sweet the biggest sweetheart
in the world do everything for me at
some point
i'm still going to want to have sex with
some strange on the side eventually at
some point she didn't even have to be
that pretty
it doesn't yeah
that was the worst day when i realized i
had to worry about the ugly girls too
they're everywhere
i also want to get to
lula's point in as well
hey can you hear me yeah yeah yep okay
yeah i'm
yeah it's really interesting what you're
all saying because from my personal
experience here
like with my partner my partner is out
of town tonight and
for me like i'm
in the best way i can be like i'm aware
that i probably am not the only woman in
his life
i i i feel like i'm gonna well up like
when i say that but it's the truth
and he um
yeah like he's to me the most amazing
guy i'm ever gonna get i'm approaching
will be approaching 40 a few years to go
and if i think that i'm gonna have this
guy all to myself he's my age as well
he's
of high status he does really well for
himself he cares about me he provides
for me he gives me a really really good
life
i'd be like crazy to think
that i'm going to be the only one
it's just not possible you know what's
even you know what's even interesting
about that is you don't even know
i don't yeah you've got no idea
it's purely
he does not he does not mention this he
i don't talk about it i don't want to
talk about it okay okay
but this is kind of a this is a little
bit of a lesson for the men watching
like
it's
not even a fact
it's the potential
of him being able to cheat and a large
part of that also comes into play when
you just told us that he's a man of
status he's high value he's well to do
right lives at a good place we know that
already we've taught us before right
and
if but if he was the opposite of that he
would if he was some schlub
didn't make any money dressed badly oh
i'm going to like birmingham for the
weekend you probably wouldn't be worried
would you i wouldn't be with him exactly
i don't know they're supposed to know
they're supposed birmingham though man
you know what she would you know what
she would probably do she'd probably
leave him for cheating
bingo women do it all the time if he was
if he's lower if he was lower or she
would cheat on him first yep which is
way more likely yep
i mean yeah i mean it's kind of like i
think girls if they know they get a guy
of a certain status will look the other
way and it's it's kind of as long as
they're not embarrassed publicly um like
what you did and personally like i
wouldn't want to be with the cheater
that's not my thing but um i i
understand the mentality of like wanting
to do that
i'll go ahead i'm sorry um yeah i was
just gonna say i think it's
people will often talk about
france and they'll talk about how in
france there's all these affairs going
on but it's always sort of secret and
it's unspoken and it's like tallulah
just described you know they don't talk
about it it's not something that's a
verb
it's something that's sort of
accepted but yeah it's cultural it's not
referred to
you keep it like that yeah
i think that's the way to do it it's
acceptable so i had i was in a
relationship with a guy for a year and a
half and i had this gut feeling no
evidence nothing
that he's a player yeah like the real
player
and i dumped him because it got stronger
and stronger
and then i started dating his friend
who's the real player here
i didn't know they're friends because
and he told me like he's the biggest
player he knows so my gut feeling was
just so all right he might have just
said that
i think this might be where you were
going justin he might have just said
that to try and like kind of yeah he
probably he probably did and that's just
weak game but i want to say something to
her that's a bad friend for a stop yeah
it is about a shitty friend and a friend
a little and this people are gonna hate
me for this but here's a little
relationship advice for your situation
if i were you i'd sit him down and say i
know what's going on
and i'm still not going to leave you
because that feeling in your gut's not
going to go away but this is what you're
costing yourself a man when he has a
feeling of guilt
he's only going to be able to love you
to about 75 or 80 percent and he's going
to keep you distant enough because if
you catch him cheating and he has
feelings for you and you leave and he
doesn't know for a fact that you'll stay
he'll hold that love back so you don't
absolutely wreck them heartbreak breaks
businesses makes people go bankrupt etc
so for me
i think
you should have the conversation with
him and i'll tell you another thing
if you were to do that and give and take
that weight off of him i think he'd love
you even more and you're guaranteed for
him never to leave you more than likely
you actually have a stronger chance are
you sure even like if you know that
you're with the guy and you tell him i
know you're cheating but i'm fine i'm
gonna stay with you doesn't will you
respect me the same way i will respect
you more way more because you can see
because here's the thing you can see the
world for what it really is so it's a
very pragmatic position to be in because
let's face it everybody in this room
knows it's going to happen it's going on
right so if you just call it out and
love them through it you are more than
likely to cinch him deeper because you
are one of now you're the one percent
woman think about it this way
one time guys i'm sorry about this
earlier like people make choices
and i think like all men have the like
they're all inclined to cheap i don't
believe that all men do if they have the
option no i don't think i think you're
right i don't i don't think they do and
i mean i don't think you know we can't
we can't say every single man is always
going to cheat you know even if he even
if he does have the options there will
be some guy he's like no i deeply love
my wife i don't believe it's the right
thing to do i'm going to pass it up i'm
not going to do it of course there are
there are those guys but i think what
we're kind of all saying is every guy
has the sort of innate yeah you know i
agree with you and many guys many guys
would act out on it if they had the
opportunity right but i think i think
like life is about choices and
consequences and i i do think there's a
sector of guys that probably would cheat
if they felt like there was no
consequence but just like it's like
imagination though yeah imagine if the
guy is suddenly finds himself in a room
with like a you know victoria's secret
model or something and there's there's
going to be no consequence to this
nobody's ever going to find out it's
going to be completely secret right
would he do it probably in many cases
yes so but some but there's a group of
guys that would say don't put me in that
room because i don't want to be tempted
to do that
yes guys
yeah sorry go ahead
this person you're talking about is a
decimal point outlier yeah and more than
likely if you take a group of men that
wouldn't do it and you pull religion and
guilt out then tell me what the number
of men would be now we're like three
decimals oh i'm sure i'm sure religion
and guilt is part of it but that's like
part of society like that like like if
if you made and in this case like this
isn't a situation where they're open and
honest with the woman like i think
cheating's wrong if you're not open and
honest with her that makes it cheating
yeah yeah and so and so what i'm saying
is like
i think there's a group of guys that
don't necessarily like partake in that
because they they don't want the
consequence that comes with it yeah
that's different that's not loyalty what
is it it's it's
fear of consequences yeah it's just fear
of consequences they still want to do it
they would still do it if they knew they
wouldn't get caught
they're already doing it in their head
to do something and not do it
yeah they should like that's like no it
would be because that's like me saying
okay i meet the i'm with a guy and i
meet a higher status guy that i'd rather
sleep with like
that's like me saying oh um there's no
loyalty like
sorry i'm trying to formulate this right
i i would still want to sleep with that
guy but because i love the person i'm
with like you choose not to you choose
not to put yourself in situations where
you're going to be tempted like that's
that's part of just being a human is
making choices well i mean it kind of
cuts both ways because there are people
in the sort of the men's manosphere
space who would believe that actually
all women would cheat if they have the
opportunity because they believe
hypergamy is so strong
that um as soon as a woman walks into a
room with uh i think all women are
tempted to cheat on somebody
but i think again you make you make
choices based on you know your loyalty
to that guy like there's always going to
be a better guy always you know what you
know what what i think we're missing
here is
you say that
but just like we were talking about
earlier when there's a dissonance you
won't sleep with a man that's a certain
level because you don't believe he's
doing anything but sleeping with you
most women will jump if they think they
can land on that branch
and what they do is start creating
stories about how how their current guy
is not doing some [ __ ] but really
it's hypergamy in action
oh he plays video game or he's not doing
this or this or some stupid [ __ ]
because if she thinks she can actually
land that guy and he won't just pump and
dump her
she'll start talking [ __ ] about the
other guy and i'm gonna tell you right
now because i get this [ __ ] a lot when
women start they'll they'll send a
facebook message or something and start
talking [ __ ] about their husband i'm
like the [ __ ] she's trying to jump
you know but at this yeah it's a monkey
branch yeah but at the same time you can
also not have social media like if
that's something you're going to as a
girl if you're going to be tempted to do
that and you made that choice you made
that lifelong commitment you cannot have
social media and like you're gonna be a
lot less tempted to do that type of
thing right or you could get a man that
keeps her frame and uh you could have
social media and he could be in the
inboxes
yeah i mean you could do that too
yeah so
if if i'm with a girl i have her
instagram i can see it when she gets a
message
oh what wow yeah what what can she see
yours what's wrong with that no
to be honest i'm thinking about it and i
am
i was just like what was you actually
mentioning but definitely between me and
my husband yeah but yeah all laptops all
phones are right open but if i was just
like
somebody a banking campaign so why
wouldn't instagram try i think we've
been together a very long time if i was
just
dating somebody or even if i'm boyfriend
and girlfriend with them
no
are you having access to my things can i
have access to yours though it doesn't
go both ways so it's only a one-way
street yeah come on that's ridiculous no
is it yes it's difficult but cheating is
different girls agree with that
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely
because because they they've quit
they've quit looking
oh because you've been honest like i am
gonna do what i'm gonna do finger no
because i'm her best option
yeah but she knows i you are going to do
what you're going to do yeah but yeah
there's zero lying okay okay
that's fine and she's cheating is women
genuinely happy yes
i think you should absolutely love the
[ __ ] out of your girl you should treat
her better than anyone we've ever
treated that's what he means he says
queens versus yeah
i mean i get it and the only reason we
call him the only reason you call hoe is
because i personally think if you call
all the other women hoes it makes your
girl feel better and as a man your job
is to paint a reality yeah yeah for her
if you really love her you need to paint
a
reality are you guys coming around are
you coming down to the whole terminology
now
[Laughter]
i know it's a lot but if i really really
love her
i want to paint a reality that makes her
life a dream
because otherwise because she can deal
with the truth but otherwise she's
sitting at home like this
young lady saying oh i think why don't
she just listen know that
my man's a [ __ ] women are trying to get
at him but he'll never leave me these
dumb hoes you think they're going to
steal my man it'll never happen and
there's a point there's a piece in that
it just really clears yourself
and not the man that's that i have an
issue with that as well so what was that
i said it's put in the the the
behavior sorry i've got the quietest
voice um putting uh the behavior on the
woman and not the man like if you you're
labeling like these hoes like they're
coming at me but actu actually is the
man that's actively going out looking
for no no why he's in a relationship
sometimes and saying yes to it and
making the choice to actually do it but
it's you don't have choices that's
exactly what it is
it's the hoes that are coming out like
yeah look at justin
but
like
but it is it is that woman's choice to
allow him to penetrate her with his
penis i was just about to say but the
man is the one that's going in yeah so
even if the guy even if the door is open
if the woman is like i'm open to you
it's the man that has decided i am going
to leave my queen to enter into this
home what does that say about the dude
he's not going to leave her queen is he
no no i mean i'm leaving her side her
bedside i'm not going to sleep with her
tonight or this minute and i'm going to
go to this ho what does that say about
the man it's in his penis that he where
is the respect it says that he's a man
like every other man and his penis has
no worth
no no
well biologically the penis really
doesn't have much worth the vagina does
because it creates life i agree
exactly right but it just makes the
point i made a while ago that no woman
has
that one quality that every man wants
which is a variety it is it's very very
hard for a lot of women to kind of
understand this and internalize it and
emotionally accept it but it's again as
amazing as you are
there's still going to be
you're still going to be tempted men are
still going to be tested by some other
but it's still about choice you've got
to remember you've got to remember as
well though the distinction between
the sexual desire and the man and love
or whatever we want to call it you know
that deeper feeling there there is a
distinction yes this whole thing
absolutely absolutely i i do think men
and women cheating is different like i
think if a woman cheats she's trying to
leave you if a man just yes yes just
like
it's like a handshake
and that's what i mean because again
yeah absolutely you can absolutely sleep
with a woman who you may find very
attractive and very sexy and everything
else but your heart is still completely
with another woman
before you sleep with that woman do you
tell them that you're in a relationship
it's our next question
yeah but okay so let me put to you like
this
i've said this on other podcasts if you
lined up every man on the planet
and you took them and you put them in a
room and you said hey listen
nobody's in here it's just us
you can hit this button
and
you can
love your wife
be an amazing father
sleep with as many hoes as you want and
then go home and hold your wife or have
sex with your wife and hold her at night
all you have to do is hit this button
and everybody will be cool with that
every man would look left he'd look
right make sure nobody's in the room and
he hit the [ __ ] button i feel like
every woman would do exactly the same no
that's what we call
what do you guys get from thinking that
women don't have exactly the same thing
it's the same level
but we're chem yeah we're chemically
different we're biologically different
like women release a chemical during sex
that men don't
so like it's i think it's fat
oxytocin yeah so so we we equate sex to
love
no we don't
well it's just a lie well women have
desires in exactly the same way every
girl i know that's done that that like
like doesn't have that feeling anymore
it's because she slept with too many
dudes but early on
like dude she lost her virginity two
second guys she slept with like she was
very attached i agree with you but could
we not say the same for men could we not
say if you if you had if you had men and
they had only slept with two women they
may have that same chemical attachment
like i loved that woman and the more
vaginas that they went into the less
they valued it and that could be the
differences i do think at some level
like that does happen like i think if a
dude sleeps with say 100 girls 200 girls
like i i do think it impacts your
ability to bond not like you can't bond
in the same way
how dare you but but i don't think but
it's not if you look at the numbers when
you rate marital happiness based on
sexual partners if a woman um has had
sex with more than five people her
chance of a happy marriage in 10 years
goes from 80 as a virgin to 25 percent
where that's where men where they they
serve no they survey people they they
just ask and who would like something so
can i finish something i need to realize
that so okay so the thing is and the
thing is with men it actually their
marital happiness
increase it's the highest as a virgin so
i do i do think that's the ideal but it
increases like their marital happiness
increases at like eight partners
so they're like more satisfied with
their wife
yeah yeah men are more happy so that
it's just more evidence that we're
biologically different
but yeah i don't think it's evidence i
just think there's like surveys and
stats just you know but so everything
would you guys you guys are the the
women in the room that do you think i
mean not necessarily talking about you
personally but do you think conceivably
you you agree with this idea then that
if a woman could press this button and
she could sleep with as many guys as she
wanted but still go home to her husband
that she'd be up for that do you think
most women would like if you eliminate
like shame in society yeah like if
you've been able to do that then yes
it's not going to be as many
as men
because it's not going to be as many
it's going to be quality so you if you
could press a button and nobody would
know
there would be certain people that you
would be like i would absolutely sleep
with that guy here we go absolutely it's
not going to be
the level of oh any any hole was a goal
it's not that this is this bingo but i
think sorry i was just going to say this
is so sorry what does that say really
quickly is that i think the
difference is
that
the man you want to come home to
will change each time
but with us it's the same woman
because you're going to sleep like let's
look you just said a second ago right oh
he's amazing i definitely want the
chance to go sleep with him yeah and
then
oh but i'm gonna come back home to this
same schlub
who's letting me cheat on a bunch of
rules are the same no they're not the
same no no no i'm not saying the rules
are different i'm saying there are many
men's and women's interpretations of
that are completely different
biologically i i hear what you're saying
i get so you're firmly fixed on this
whole idea that when a woman sleeps with
a man there's going to be this chemical
bond not necessarily no no but if but if
you feel like the dicks let's say let's
look let's just use
let's just use
that's actually true that's totally true
that's true but let's just say for
example like let's just purely use
numbers to make it easy right let's say
your husband is a five yeah right just
arbitrarily i know i don't know who the
man i'm just i'm just throwing for the
arbitrary sake let's say he's a five
right and then this rule comes into
place yeah cool all right you meet a
handsome producer over here
right okay you're like all right bang
and then you have to come home to him
yeah there's a five
yeah [ __ ] okay cool and then the next
day
you do the same thing again and the next
day do the same thing again the next day
the same thing again eventually you're
like i don't want to keep coming home to
this [ __ ] i want to come home
for that [ __ ] right and you're
saying that is very different for men
men don't feel that way totally
different
i could i can that's why i love men that
i could leave their wives for a
secretary that doesn't happen
well they do because
the reason they do though is because the
secretary's giving them something that
the wife isn't giving
and that's and that is in the most in
most cases in most cases the secretary
is giving him peace
can i can i look for caveats okay i'm
just saying okay
also what you said is very important he
leaves to marry the secretary
so what he's going to do there
is he could sleep with a woman we'll
call her a lady
every night yeah we're getting there it
was good
dude i don't hate women at all i love
women
um
but what you notice is that
he is now going to love that girl so if
if he
leaves his wife which is probably aged
and all that other all those other
things if i'm being honest okay and he's
probably leaving her for a woman that
probably looks up to him if it's their
secretary he's in a power position with
her the other respects it because he's
in the position the other one's at the
country club it doesn't respect him the
same way spins all his money spends all
his money nags not happy and so he
leaves and notice what he does though he
marries her guess what he's still
sleeping with ladies
and he wants to come home to the second
wife and he probably loves her i fell in
love at least twice in my life yeah he's
just changed the queen right and people
yeah i think the fact that guys and
women i suppose but the fact that guys
will fall out of love with the queen as
we're saying here is i think a slightly
separate issue to this desire to yeah
it is different it's because men and
women fall in love in different ways
like men um fall in love through like
quality time and loyalty where women
fall in love through sex so if you have
sex like have you ever heard you okay
you've never heard the term dickmatized
yeah but
sterling's
you're just literally
just like how men have lost it's exactly
this i would argue that's how women feel
love is like when they're when they're
like okay i'll give you a story okay so
there was a girl i went to college with
and you would never know this is like
the girl next door okay she dated a guy
freshman year of college they dated for
like a month okay they broke up
he dumped her whatever like he was the
player right she gets with a guy her
senior year
this man buys her a house she's like it
gives her everything she ever wants a
ring whatever down the line
i went to a party with this girl okay
and at that party
i saw her
walk out of the bathroom after she'd
been in there for like 20 30 minutes um
because we were like waiting to go with
the guy from freshman year who does she
love
who does she not so you would have to
ask her
so who was she going to leave she was
still sleeping with the guy from
freshman year
for years yeah that's what i'm saying
like like oh and the crazy thing not
loved because the sex was good yeah it's
it's a habit and no ice is an
attachment but that doesn't make it love
women don't cheat on men they love yeah
must be taking the piss
hey have you considered this maybe maybe
you're taking the piss because you
believe something that's never going to
happen
i think a lot of times women find
themselves very very upset and feeling
alone and went through a bunch of men
and
unhappy
single no kids cat boxes box wine
netflix alone because they bought
the dream that prince charming was going
to come on a horse and be rich and be
handsome and be tall and not [ __ ] a
bunch of ladies i i hear what you're
saying and i think that that is sorry
that is the reality for um for
unfortunately for a lot of women because
we are socialized to be to have this
romantic notion of relationships and
that this prince charming is going to
come and that sort of thing but
at the same time especially like someone
my age and like just seeing the women
around me that kind of filters out like
we the way we've been socialized it's
just not the reality anymore we can see
the the the smoke um we could see
through the smoke
and lighter your whole life yeah yeah
you have no way
and that's the thing and i think that a
lot of women are waking up to this fact
that actually this is a myth this is
nonsense like that's never going to
happen so
so what you're saying why aren't women
settling
why are they selling no why aren't they
yeah women are selling that's why
statistically that's so high no that's
not true like half of women over 30 are
single and childless
half of women oh you mean like settling
for an average yeah like getting an
average guy and everything
80 percent of women want 20 of them so
if you ask 80 of women what they want in
a guy they list 20 percent of men so the
men that we want there's just not enough
to go around yeah they do so sorry so we
always say
so we always talk we always talk about
like never settle never settle never
settle but we just end up alone no i
think i think a lot of women settle
maybe that's not um
obvious to people but a lot of women are
sailing i think and because we have so
much pressure in society that you can't
be alone you can't be happy and alone or
you can't you know i mean that you don't
have a fulfilling life if you don't have
children and that is that is a problem
but like society's viewpoint needs to
change but no because the thing is if
you choose to have a relationship and be
in the scenario that you're talking
talking about with full honesty that's
one thing that's okay do you know what i
mean but if you're choosing not to that
should also be okay you shouldn't be
victimized or demonized because you
choose something it's not that it's not
it's not that you're demonized though
like i think
because one i see propaganda all the
time talking about how like women over
40 are super happy like i see this all
the time like oh it's okay to be alone
never settle da da da da like i see the
opposite propaganda honestly and on top
of that like women 45 single and
childless are the least happy
demographic
i just don't know how you prove that no
no because they survey people
they serve it they certainly this is
this is what this is what i mean like i
know no i'm not like the same but it
just seems so general and it just seems
like i i just like pulling we're
biologically programmed to want children
yeah i would not naturally everybody
you're right not everybody is but the
majority of us are and typically when i
see a woman that doesn't want kids like
she somehow was hurt in the past and
that's why she doesn't it's like i think
i start out i think every woman starts
her life out wanting a family in kids
and then at some point
society gets in her head
bad experiences get in her head and that
warps that the woman that says she
doesn't want kids is just as much of an
outlier as a man that says he doesn't
want to cheat
bingo hold on
mike drop you're very funny
you're not actually right and you have
nothing to say to it i am right you're
wrong
i just i i don't
agree with the fact that oh no it
doesn't feel good it's a fact it's it's
not even a fact because it's how it
feels really isn't about how it feels
it's just like having a lived experience
and having people around that have
actually gone through this and this is
their experience and them not being this
these idea these these
these mythical women that you think they
are do you know what i mean right so 65
you're gonna like you're 65 yeah and
you're going to live another 20 30 like
let's say you lived in 90.
you're going to be happy no family
nothing just by yourself with a career
so you know you will say no family as in
no kids of your own yeah no kids no
husband okay
you don't have friends it doesn't mean
that you don't have family rooms got
children nieces and nephews you know
what i mean so there are other ways to
find happiness and i think that that is
okay and i just don't like the fact that
you know it's pushed that it's not okay
and then for women to be pushed into
relationships that they're not happy in
it and they're not going to be fulfilled
in and like do you know what i mean i
just think it just needs to be equal or
level but i don't know what i'm not
saying is it's not okay i think people
can if you want to do that if like
people want to do that do it but what i
think is dishonest is lying to women and
telling them you're going to be happy
without a husband without a family at 65
because if we take if we take sample
sizes we survey women that are single
childless at 65 in different cities
across the country
it comes with the same result they're
the least happy and so you can say oh i
don't believe the data but like how much
i understand maybe you don't believe me
maybe like that's that's another thing
but like how much evidence do you need
if people themselves are saying i am the
least happy demographic when they are
serving i would need to see the data
okay and i have a comment on the data as
well i took this um yale university
course on happiness
and they did a study and they found that
your happiness level
is gonna be up two years when you get
married and then it's gonna it's gonna
go down to the same level when you are
single mm-hmm well hollywood period
isn't it really yeah right right so
which is also biological yes yeah make
sure the kid makes it yes bingo oh
interesting i didn't know that yeah
who's going to keep who's going to keep
the pregnant woman alive and make sure
the baby gets through infancy yeah yeah
it's about 18 months that's why they say
also if you're dating a girl then you
don't have kids so if you've why a lot
of relationships sort of split after
about two years two three years it's
because if you haven't produced a child
then sort of biologically you know
internally the woman and the band
probably like what's the point yeah
exactly exactly there's nothing bonding
them together yeah it's just yeah right
and other mammals like giraffes they
they have the baby and the baby pops out
of walk yeah you know but that's not
like that with a human baby we're
different
yeah it's different that thing is
useless yeah for two years kind of a
walk
in different yeah defenseless yeah
i don't i don't get what you guys are
saying because more people are in like
long relationships and they don't
generally get married
yeah it's like i don't see how this that
would stack up to this two-year thing
how many
more people are living together honest
question for longer how many like
long-term married couples do you know
that are like um
but that are
super happy who's who
you should really be asking me is how
many people do i know
that are super happy that's what i'm
asking you but that would be the you
know couples it goes up and down how
many couples do i know that have been in
long-term relationships quite a few
of those how many of them are like how
many of them are i only okay so i have
eight friends who have been in a
relationship as long as me and my
husband 20 years cool
congratulations by the way that's
actually amazing and only one
of them
has just got divorced and we all kind of
got together divorced no i'm saying
but all of us are
as happy as the next human next door
it's like you go up and down
cooper the happiest man
in our unions or we would get divorced
no and that's great and that's the thing
but so there's quite a few if you're in
that vortex if you're not i'm going to
see the opposite i don't think
that
people can people will
immediately divorce if they're unhappy
in a relationship well i think it would
be stupid
if somebody came to me and was like i'm
not
i'm really unhappy in my marriage
i want to get a divorce i'd be like
no
that's not the step you take clever
there are loads of things that you work
on because happiness goes up and down
it's a scale it's just lots of things
will make you happy what you really want
is contentment and you want to be secure
and you want to have a super objective
for your life and if the person works
with that and you can fulfill that
that's where you want to be because
happiness is fleeting you know the best
the best super objective is
children kids
um they they can't be the only thing
because obviously
they'll leave you well that is the best
example of a superhero yeah well it's at
least 18 years
it's one of them it's one to have it's
one to have to keep you bonded to but
then your super objective doesn't
necessarily have to be having the child
it should really be more of the type of
human that you actually want to
co-create and actually build to be
significant and productive in society
and that would be your super objective
it's not to just have the baby because
you could have the child and their
bloody hard work
make the child a killer make their child
amazing i agree with that that's right
that can be your objective for you know
20 years i know that's mine and then
maybe that's my objective you can change
again because we live so long now and
then you can be like we've done what we
set out to do for our 25 years and maybe
me and you can just be bread rooms and
we can move on again or or
we redirect that energy again that's it
if it works
our kids kids yeah and that's cool and
then we can be effective grandparents
you can go in that way and it's called
legacy too the other so
we are talking about women that are
single and childless over a certain age
the other issue with that is that
there's a large proportion of women that
will be on the streets because they
don't have the 2.5 million that they
need to retire
2.5 million you need 2.5 million too in
the uk
oh i'm sorry this is a u.s stat i forget
about that i forget that the structure
is different
i mean we have pensions
the idea is that well
in the u.s the idea is that a lot of the
government handouts are going to run out
because it's just not
sustainable long-term
yeah so when the day that comes when
they actually have to stop giving
government handouts there's a lot of
women that are going to be on the
streets because we own 80 of consumer
debt
yeah
goddamn yeah so so
yeah including college debt yeah and
college debt is the biggest i mean
that's that's a u.s issue here i think
the school is free but yeah no you still
have that but you don't pay it you don't
pay it back unless you reach a certain
level of income yeah you don't have to
yeah oh okay that's actually and it cuts
out at 65 or something does it right
yeah yeah it does it's a third year
right right okay yeah i don't i don't
know all the time just just like just
play devil's advocate on that point a
little bit though is it is should
somebody therefore say oh well in case i
end up on the street and i i haven't got
2.5 million when i'm 65 i should
therefore check out with the dude i
would
i mean yeah but
let's be completely clear
everybody in this room would every one
of you ladies would because you'd have
no choice and that's the way it was
before all this [ __ ] yeah i was just
like saying so we'll just go back to the
50s where you're literally what no 18
years
when you needed to be married to just
have a bank account so you just go you'd
be in your old age and you'd be like
okay i'm going to shack up with winston
down the road and so then i can't
survive winston's great is it
a little ramen noodle some netflix might
have sex counterproductive to the whole
woman being an independent woman and so
that's why she hasn't set her sights out
to be married would she not have been
stacking her peas so she would be okay
at 65. probably better than others
like the average income of a i don't
know what it is here but i know it's
similar so in the u.s the average income
of a woman is around 35 000
so so she she doesn't have enough money
to stack her p's and be the independent
woman if you look at the numbers like
what percent of women are making six
figures it's not a very high amount yeah
it's less than ten i would like to see
in relation to single women who are over
40
and how much money they are earning but
in that 25 years that how many of them
would be the ones that would be homeless
i i would
say that it's probably not going to be
that high there may be some i mean you
know whatever happens but again people
aren't family-less like they do have
relatives they do have siblings there
are other people that are in their
family i don't think there'll be that
many
people well but the thing is like women
are the
biggest growing homeless population
so so it's happening you could say like
oh i don't think that many of them it'll
happen to you but if 50 of women over 30
are single and childless that's a very
big percentage of the population those
are interesting ways of saying stats
though because whenever you say growing
it's like when people say like um
mixed-race children are the the biggest
growing ethnicity in the uk they are
still like literally like 0.2
so
growing doesn't mean that we should be
like oh it's gonna happen it's just
maybe there's more
i know there's but there's more stats
that i'm bringing to you like i'm
telling you that 50 of the population is
single and childless you need 2.5
million to retire and on top of that the
average income of a woman is 35 000 per
year or four
it's between 35 and 45. it's around
there a year in the united states and
it's similar here so and on top of that
the biggest growing homeless population
is single childless women so it's it's
like all of those numbers together
show that you know that's not
like the single modern women it's that's
not a good look for them i don't even
want to say look it's not good outcomes
or
the outcomes that were there before when
you were settling for a man and getting
beaten up and we're thoroughly unhappy
and having loads of kids then you don't
have any choices to do yeah i'm just
saying
we're doing sweeping statements so i'm
offering another counter too no i know
maybe this is the shift of reality well
what evidence do you have that women
were being beat like do you think the
majority of men were beating up women in
the 1950s no it wasn't the majority but
there was a large amount and you also
didn't have the means the capacity or
the societal support to leave so you
stayed in relationships because that's
what you had to do now that's shifting
now so you don't have to be in a
relationship so maybe the offshoot of
that is that some people are not going
to be in a relationship they would have
lived their life they would have spent
their money how they were going to spend
their money and they may have loads of
debt but
that could just be a consequence of
freedom cool i some people would decide
i want to be free then have to be bonded
to an average man yeah but yeah i would
also add to what you're saying is yeah
maybe you're right but the reason she is
right is because big daddy government
has stepped in and given women
this other way they're going to give
them all these jobs but what she's
saying is because they only make 35
grand a year because they don't have the
2.5 million because we are running out
the ball's about to drop on that what
what would you do if let's just say
tomorrow
an emp drops on the whole world
electro big big pulse internet's gone
all computers are gone we're back to the
stone age right what would you do then
would you okay some guy some guy who's
average
comes along is like i want to marry you
and put a baby in you and raise a family
with you we've got this farmland we're
going to grow crops by the way i can
hunt by the way i can shoot a gun and
haunted deer
i i've oh no sorry you're not good
looking enough no no i'm not on it like
all of that like massive changes it's
cool i can go with the smash and and
leave so i'm too old go and find someone
younger okay so it's a it's a product of
the times
really yeah the situation we find
ourselves in right now is a product of
the times we're in which is this like
justin just said this kind of
nanny state
right the government is
most people are suckling on the teat of
government in some way shape or form
right or they're being parasitized by
the government
if you're actually producing money and
you're being parasitized your taxes are
massive right i mean we don't live in
this country but we're in a different
country and we know that's the case
so
it it
we
find ourselves in this really
unique time in history
where
men and women
are being
put in a combative situation
rather than a complementary one
we're naturally complementary to each
other we're supposed to be together well
we we take away the consequence so like
before if you were if you were single
and alone you'd be you'd be homeless
and now there's no consequence for that
because the government's bailing people
out
can i ask a question to the ladies on
the panel
i don't want to rephrase this uh okay
[Laughter]
let's get through your question first
and if we've got time i'll bring it up
you do your things first okay um i was
just gonna read some super chat yeah
okay
um oh wow we got a decent oh these just
keep going um oh i know that's from last
show
okay
um okay
albert nando retro
boo don't let your guy cheat that's a
good way to catch something nobody
should cheat if you're if you can't be
faithful don't get involved okay you're
awesome white knight white knight can i
have a really question about stds what
about stds literally i'm sure i'm an
adult film star
my entire job is to have sex raw if you
get tested that doesn't happen
so just get a blood test you don't ask
i swear um i swear adult film starts
have like the highest rates of st
they're the lowest
because we literally get tested every 14
days and everyone we have sex with get
tested every 14 days
you are more like i i can say this is
purely experience
but you are far more likely to catch an
std from somebody at a rave
than you ever will from work having sex
with someone who's actually a sex worker
because a sex worker's income
is literally tied
to the to the cleanliness of the junk
but you can't um
isn't there what's that oh my gosh i
can't think of it off the top of my head
isn't there that std that like everyone
has
yeah it's that one and there's one
hp hpv yeah like i would imagine they
have to have that if you have sex with
that many so
we can like i can go down the tribe hole
if you want yeah a little bit just a
little yeah quick i'm not an expert at
hpv
i am i know like you're an expert on uh
so with herpes there's there's type one
type two there's the the the oral
version and the general version and i
think something like 70 of the human
population
has
one of these two types of happy however
yes correct however
not a very very tiny percentage of the
human population actually experiences
what you call outbreaks which allow the
virus to trans uh to well
that
that's one way that the virus can move
from person to person you could have
caught like and this is why i tell
people to get a goddamn blood test
you probably how many people quick raise
of hands
how many people in this room have had an
std test
in their life i think i've always ever
how many have had an std test in the
last year
in the last six months
three months
so for those who
we're at home uh you and me with
anyone's for six and three yes and
that's one two three four five six seven
eight nine people in the room what about
monkey parks
don't break that on troy
so
you can get the blood test and determine
if you have okay yeah uh hiv chlamydia
gonorrhea right and then you can also
get the blood test for herpes but then
what do you think
right sorry but really quickly like
like 70 of the human population have one
of the two types of herpes and
a very very subset of that have the
actual outbreaks but you can spread it
without having an outbreak you probably
got if you actually have herpes you
probably got it from being kissed on the
forehead or your lips as a child by your
parents
right so that's
it's not a life-threatening disease
either things like chlamydia right or is
it the one that al capone had can
actually kill you but is it wouldn't you
guys be at a hot like higher person just
because you're getting tested you're
still sleeping with way more people than
no because everyone we're sleeping with
is also getting tested and we're not
allowed to shoot if we have anything
okay but i don't that's what
i just swore i saw a study that said
that like porn oh gosh corn you have to
say corn corn stars have higher higher
rates of stds i swore that i did but i
could be incorrect so i'm not going to
speak on something i don't know
you said it's
speaking to the mic every 14 days we get
tested yeah blood and urine every 14
days sterling do you tell me they don't
even check for herpes
in the industry no
no nice that shows you how serious
herpes must be exactly for them
like it's like i'm i would be scared
shitless to get hiv
like and from the stats i just told you
like and i'd be scheduled again i forget
which one al capone had it was the clap
i think it was a clap well maybe it was
gonna rain but it's a clown which can
actually kill you yeah and you will die
like it [ __ ] with your brain it's
horrible like you don't know what you
don't want to get that and and have it
stick around for a long time again while
i'm telling everyone get a goddamn std
test get a blood test so you know if
you've got it you can get rid of it
quickly right
the herp
again like 70 of human population
something like that has it
it ain't killing anybody yeah it it's
it's like a nasty thing
but if they have it
there's um
anti-retrovirals what's the name of the
damn thing um
yeah i'm taking the valacyclovir
psychology something like this right
which works for like the oral and the
genital stuff and that like it literally
just destroys it and keeps it at bay
there's dudes in my industry who've been
working for like 20 plus years
i'm not going to name names there's guys
that i know in my industry 20 plus year
veterans award winners have had
the hope their career and they've never
passed it on because they keep taking
the same medication and they've kept
working their entire career and they
never they've never given it to a
co-star because they because they're
responsible they take the medication
they're like [ __ ]
they're not running around like ah i've
got a saw yeah i'm gonna put my dick in
somebody like they're actually
responsible with it yeah and that that's
kind of the deciding factor but that is
not something that people need to be
super super worried about it's the hiv
chlamydia gonorrhea
that was a weird tangent yeah
okay i'm gonna go to the next super chat
so
um
affy kingdom uh appreciate the internet
oh you guys know him oh yeah yeah yeah
he's a man it's that guy is he does he
have a channel or something he does yeah
he does oh okay um appreciate the
international boss players respect
pearly peace to my bros sterling j
waller and troy francis um red pill
hustle
um 50 super chat thank you
um fantastic topic i think more women
should understand us men are wired the
bit wired this way and once they come to
terms with how men are they'd love
much more happily in a relationship kiwi
space space it's all about how you value
what you value and the relationship if
you value trust loyalty and commitment
you wouldn't stay with the cheater pure
manipulation the savvy ninja you can't
simply dismiss every stat to hang on to
the myth in your head i'm sorry ladies
you aren't listening
men and women aren't the same in
anything and then the very least a few
things jc
the
justin waller sterling cooper and troy
francis in london getting some quote tea
and crumpets uh get your planned bees
out ladies
sandra solomon um these men are
literally literally made me want to give
up on dating i've won a wrongful death
suit and i can tell you that money
doesn't buy a piece of mind true
okay
um
so
my next question i have for the people
um do you think that money like actually
this is for the women do you think that
money buys a man's ability to cheat
good question
i think it can do yeah i think it can i
think um you just see that with
celebrities really
do you know what i mean like um
[Music]
god the only example i can think of at
the moment is cardi b
um but
you know
officer yeah beyonce as well like people
just i love beyonce but people literally
say
all of her albums are just basically her
arts and jay-z to stop cheating on
basically
um and yeah it's just you know they
they they don't leave do you know what i
mean that means she's still in love by
the way say again that means she's still
in love with him by the way i i don't
know if you can separate the brand and
what they built and legacy and all of
that kind of stuff i think it that goes
into it as well like you're not just
walking away from a person and how they
make you feel but you're working walking
away from your livelihood what your kids
yeah and your kids of course yes yes of
course um but yeah so i think it's it's
not that easy when you're in those kind
of statuses
um
but i do i do think it can it can it can
sway people
yeah
um yeah yeah i agree i'm i was just
thinking of quite a few
people that i know that have dated men
with lots of money
and there's a thing of actually like
going after not your equivalent so
you're going to go after a woman who
doesn't have as much as you
and so then you hold them in a vac of
like the lifestyle that i can give you
and then you treat them in a way that
isn't very pleasant and i think a lot of
men hold on to that and they kind of
keep that cycle going and while there's
quite a few
women that you can have access to that
are really good looking but are actually
like quite poor
bad behavior can be allowed because
you're funding a lifestyle for them i
think lots of guys that with a lot of
money know this and so those are the
women that they go after they don't
generally go after their contemporaries
you know i don't i don't necessarily
think it's money alone because i think
that money like
a guy could win the lottery tomorrow and
it doesn't mean women will want him like
that it's got to be status or
competence
it's got to be all yeah so i always say
that there's buckets
um
at some point when the money bucket
fills up
let's say whatever the number is let's
say it's i don't know
a million dollars just for a round
number when the money bucket fills up i
say i would never trade places with mark
zuckerberg this is a [ __ ] dork
so when men lead with their wallet it's
weak
and respect equals love and you can't
respect a man
who is only rich and hasn't handled
fitness or competency or become a
certain type of man i agree as a as a
man
or to have a healthy relationship i feel
like the woman does need to look up to
the man she needs to feel like her life
is being better because of him and you
can't only do that with money because
that's not really a relationship it's
just legal prostitution and it's larping
it's fake
so
when
when a woman
cheats on a rich man or she's with a
rich man but she's not happy it's
because he didn't fill all those other
buckets up
he doesn't understand how to paint that
picture that gives her this reality
how to take her through time and space
how to make her feel like she she's the
star in the movie because no man and
this is a point to what you're talking
about as far as being equal the reason i
think that's wrong is because no man
wants a woman that he can't save from a
castle and dragon the day a man can no
longer be a hero for a woman is the day
that he'll probably check out
if i can't if i can't be your hero then
i don't want to save you so you really
think that all men have that savior
complex like it's inherent in normal i
think it is inherent in most guys yeah i
agree that's that's what makes love so
beautiful i think men just have a
naturally like want they want to protect
women yeah especially the women like
that they're like they're girlfriends or
whatever
um
because
i mean you kind of see it in society
like there's so many double standards
that like women get away with that men
don't
um like for example
like the amber heard case
and it's because i just think men
naturally like have an ability to like
believe and like protect women
yeah and i think that's the most
beautiful thing about love
a man should protect a woman and it's
very it's it very much lines up with
nature because if men checked out
women would die
no offense no offense to you but
but men invent
build and maintain everything and i
don't mean that as a diss on women i
really only will go so deep and so hard
on this subject
because i love women because one day i'm
going to have a daughter
and all i want for her is for her to
truly understand how this deal works
and then i want her to take that
information and have choice
if she wants to
marry a woman that's fine i love you
baby if she wants to sleep with a bunch
of men and be called a
whatever a lady whatever
or
whatever she wants to do
but
i i love women
and i feel like it's a [ __ ] shame
that we lie to him on such a massive
level because whether you believe those
stats or not
she's not the only person using those
stats these stats are true if they
weren't true then i wouldn't be able to
go into my inbox and find hundreds of
messages from women
they're they're single they're alone i
suspect they're probably not happy and
if i really really care about women and
i do
hopefully one day my daughter will see
this
then i would much rather tell them the
truth so they can take the truth and at
least have a chance at choice
a chance right now they don't have a
chance they're being lied to
but do you see this um
what you you mentioned as like the
savior complex like do you not think
that it's just the same
like kind of fairy tale that women are
told about the prince in shining armor
that the men are literally just playing
that right i think he probably is to
some extent because then you get like
white nights so then you get guys who
will step in and you mention amber heard
and i mean that that sort of situation
would be an example where guys will step
in to sort of protect the woman even
though actually the woman doesn't
necessarily merit protection so yeah i
think guys have their own form of disney
fantasy as well for sure and that's why
it's men's fault the problem truly is
weak men
because what happens is he comes in
and he's larping i'll use the word again
he's telling her all this so he can
sleep with her all these things and then
when she what really upsets her is she
realized this dude lied to me
he's not this great man he says he is
then she starts looking the other
direction we hate weak man yeah
absolutely as you should biologically
you should because look at every other
species right every other species
the the strong
male i'm not going to say the the word
but the strong male is the one that's
doing all the mating yeah and why would
that be because the species wants the
best exactly reproductive
quality in children but that's why i
have a huge problem with outfits like
fresh and fit
because you're coming after women and
you're teaching men how to mac and
actually you're not teaching them how to
be
really what they say is alphas you're
not you're just teaching them
as well but no one watches that [ __ ]
they do teach that i think i think
that's just just to speak up for those
guys they they absolutely do i mean
there's this whole thing now in this
community in this space online where
people are talking about money muscles
game and frame you know and it really is
about covering all the bases and i mean
fresh and fit they've got their money
podcasts they i mean myron was a fitness
is a fitness guy i feel special so they
do they do cover and they also
and then they add in the mackin
it's like
just you're literally just going around
presenting yourself as something that
you're not and then painting women to be
the villains of the piece so you're
saying like they're presenting
themselves as like alphas and yeah i
don't know but they don't they don't say
that they're alphas like they've never
said that in any show well they are
right they do purport to try and teach
people how to be better at
so i mean that's that's what they teach
it's like a men's self-improvement show
so they teach men how to make more money
they teach men how to get in better
shape they they teach men how to talk to
women because as much as like we might
want to [ __ ] on game and stuff like i
love me a smooth talker like
like i love you like
i'm not even going to cap and and so you
know at least they're helping men become
better men and become the men we want to
be with i don't think i don't believe
that anybody
with any credibility in the in that
space is teaching guys to be something
they're not i think if you are i think
that then there is a problem with you as
a coach and a content creator i think
what most people are saying myself
included but also as you know the fresh
and fit guys and everybody really is
saying be the best man that you can be
um but also present yourself in the best
way possible and that does involve some
degree you also have to understand real
up really quickly during interjection is
that
the the dating
marketplace that we are currently in in
2022 right unfortunately
you can be
the best product in the world
you could say say joe from
somewhere in the middle of england okay
right he is what was that wigan in wigan
cool he's now he's in wigan joey wigan
is a multi-millionaire he it would be a
fantastic father he's got the best
values in the world he will
you know look after you like build a
great
future for you
but
he is
a terrible smooth talker
he's the best product but his marketing
is [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and right now we
live in a world a day and age where the
marketing is basically everything
instagram
your photos how you present yourself
your social media that is the marketing
in today's day and age and dating
unfortunately for men especially
advising for men because if you suck at
marketing
you ain't getting any attention you get
no chances you could be the best product
but if you're marketing your [ __ ] you're
done can i please speak into them
it could be someone that has good
marketing and have great pictures and
show all this great life
but then when you go and meet them they
could be the practice guy with no no but
they could they could be a guy with no
boundaries with like no game no nothing
totally true and that's that's the
actual problem walter and myron
walter and myron and fresh and fit
walter and meyer are absolute [ __ ]
heroes
i'll tell you why okay of course they
help with muscle of course they help
with money and helping understand money
but the number one thing that they do
is help young men understand female
nature and both men and women need to
thank myron and walt for exposing that
amen now it might not be at the same
polarity of a miami ho
but if a man understands female names
miami lady
[Laughter]
no those girls are hugs bro
so but if a man understands this female
nature truly
the problem
in addition to more in addition to mario
keating is actually
management project management
you need to understand female
female nature
if you understand female nature you are
more likely substantially more likely to
keep your woman happy because when she
[ __ ] texts you and she doesn't know why
and you crack back and she's like god
that was [ __ ] sexy i'll never leave
this man
i'm telling you
myron and walt are [ __ ] heroes
this is the thing it's just like if i'm
going to learn from a man like how
um they think or how um do you know what
i mean like just just learn in general
just from a man's point of view
i i
like
the way that they dehumanize women the
the the terms that they use like what
issues it's just exactly things like
hoes and all of that kind of stuff and i
just think it's like what's all that
kind of stuff though sorry i hear you
say hose but what's all that other kind
of stuff
um they kind of don't look like do you
do you think that they think about women
nicely do you feel that women speak on
their show they kind of like can be
derogatory sometimes nine out of 10
women on that show have an only fans
account where they sell nudes for money
okay but that doesn't mean that they
should be talked to anyhow or like but
it shows the type of character that that
the girl is because she takes the easy
way out does that mean you should talk
to talk but here's but here's the thing
here's the thing i will
wait i will agree with you that i do
think they're rude at times like i'm a
polite person so sometimes like they can
be rude but like they're helping men and
that's that's their end goal
i just can i just take issue
i mean i've been on the show for a
couple of times and and uh i mean
justin's been on and stirring a bit on
it more times than me but i've been on a
couple of times i've known myron for a
few years and and like when you're there
i mean i i sort of fundamentally
disagree that they're disrespectful to
the women because actually they will
they will always give everyone an
opportunity to come in yes you know um
and and if a male guest actually is is
talking too much something they'll calm
them down say no let her come in and you
and even when you see them before the
program and they're interacting with the
women and everything it's very very
respectful there's no sort of you know
that that because they i mean apart for
anything else they know that you know
these women are kind of make what part
of what's making the show so popular but
they i i would fundamentally disagree
that they are in any way being sort of
like deliberately derogatory towards the
women i mean what's being displayed may
appear derogatory but that's often
because of the way the women are
behaving yeah that's that's the other
thing oh no
seriously well i think what you're
mixing up is the
the message
versus the entertainment part
they've seen myron tell a girl
hey do you understand like in a way that
he kind of knows that she might piss
back at him yeah and then he can boot
her but that's the entertainment side of
that show yeah that's what i don't know
i just said yeah that's what you don't
like the reason it's the reason you're
watching it right yeah yeah
the reason most people are watching it
that is true
that's it's the jerry springer of our
age
this show
but that is the unfortunately that's
human nature
look at why was jerry springer so
popular speaking to the mic sorry
i'm so sorry
but just a couple of things just like
you know um it's not necessarily human
nature because the you know as well all
in podcasts and stuff like it sits on
youtube so if you watch something then
you're usually going to be served
something again so where is normally in
real life if you don't like a
conversation you can just walk away but
you know i mean on youtube it will just
continue to be surfing do people that i
don't i don't agree with that do people
walk away from like i've seen people
sitting there and arguing for hours
in person i don't think they walk away
yeah they do i mean yeah i don't think
people get the first fights
fist fights would not exist if people
walked away from conversation
my point is just that you know it's not
it's it's it's kind of like an unnatural
way to con consume things like that and
i just think that
i i just have a real issue with it and
so where i'm making a face is because
it's my genuine reaction that it makes
me uncomfortable because i feel that
they do a lot of damage to their
audience
those women can give as good as they get
as well right i mean some of those women
are like real you know the thing is it's
more about the audience right yeah the
people that are watching it and if they
go out into the world and then speak to
women like that as well or think it's
okay or don't understand like okay we
can understand maybe because we're in it
and we're exposed and all that kind of
stuff but the average person watching it
they don't necessarily understand that
it's just dramatization they don't
and i think it's irresponsible to
continuously perpetuate that kind of
message but what are they what are they
they're not telling them how to like i
don't know what what have they
specifically said where they tell
abandoned like call women hoes or call
women there no but they don't have to do
that what it is is about
just subtly repeatedly putting in
certain messages into their content or
talking to women in a certain way and
repeating that process over and over
again where it becomes the mourn so
therefore you don't have to say that a
ver statement you can just subscribe but
that's you reading between the lines
though that's that's you like taking how
yeah like you can't say they didn't say
it but this is what they're saying but
but couldn't you say the same about like
you know hip-hop music and all that
stuff i mean
just like what are you saying sorry well
that that kind of terminology was used a
lot particularly like 90s like rap and
all that kind of stuff i mean it's not
right eva
but at the same time if you walk in a
club tonight
women everywhere are dancing and shaking
their ass to [ __ ] these hoes i'm
cheating on this [ __ ] and it's cool
when it's little wayne saying it's
totally true they're they're super about
i love it this is my [ __ ] blah blah blah
and then but then when it happens and
that's the culture that fresh and fit
yeah it's really much very much tapped
into is that you know
american rap culture sort of street kind
of right i get it so the lingo is
attached to that as a member of that
culture it's it's a bit much that's what
i'm saying i have a question for you
have you ever
really delved into fresh and fits
content do you watch it to a point where
you could say i understood their channel
i've watched their content because
what um some of the guests were saying
were
you're only seeing their content from
the viral clips and the viral clips of
the entertainment and that's the stuff
that
would be deemed but the thing is
disagreeable i i hear what you're saying
and this this argument often comes up
but then the thing is it's just like
well if everybody's not watching do you
know what i mean like if everyone's
watching everyone's full content then
cool then we have then we're on an equal
step you have context that's not that's
not the same thing and it's just like
you get these
headline
type stats and things like that that are
used to make points but i have to do a
whole thesis on this to make a point no
it's not a full thesis it's like okay i
i just understand a lot where they're
coming i agree like sometimes they're
they're a bit rude for me like i'm kind
of i understand where you're coming from
but it's just
when you're running a show a lot of
times like there are times where i'm i'm
very rude to a guest and i cut them off
but it's only because they've
interrupted me 10 times
so i'm so unreasonable yeah
and
and so and so and as a as a show host
like it you you're very disrespected
because you put on all this time into
paying the producers you put all this
time into getting the guests you put all
this time and energy and effort just to
have a guest that keeps interrupting you
and so by the 10th time you're like
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up like that's what
most people do and a lot of times like
when their clips go viral like and i i
can't remember i wish i could quote it
off the top of my head but i can't but
the one like rapper that came in that
they kicked out that like went super
viral yeah it was because like he told
them like 10 times to stop talking and
then she like she wouldn't do it and she
showed him coaches
yeah and she showed up late like the
these guys are pretty big guests
yeah
yeah these guys were pretty big guests
for my channel they showed up on time
and like it's just
you know and it's just like it's like a
level of respect and you don't always
see the context of the room and i think
that's that's something that most people
don't understand about you know martin
and walter fresh and fit right they're
personal friends of ours we love them to
death
and they have like their hearts are in
the right place yeah they really really
want to tell both men and women i can
tell you this as a man who knows them
personally all right but
again
to reiterate your point that is
like
if you
people have so much entitlement in
today's day and age they really do like
oh i got invited on fresh podcast oh
cool i'm gonna rock up late drink all
their alcohol
be have my social medias blown up by
their
a million subscriber audience have all
my only fans account blown up by their
million subscriber audience which does
happen we know it happens right and
they're still
gonna
talk speak out of line be disrespectful
to myron because he said something they
don't agree with
they're gonna be really rude to him and
try to talk over the top of him right
not obey the house rules like a producer
here kind of laid down before similar
thing right
it comes from this place of entitlement
it's a real lack of respect
those are the women that they're
inviting on there i don't know how you
guys can say and they're your friends so
i feel i i'm giving you a lot of grace i
think you're blinded by your friendship
with these guys but if they are really
trying to help men
why do they have such a set type of
woman that comes onto their shoulder i
can answer this
and then and then be so horrible to them
when you're really trying to help men
when a lot of these men have real
problems with women in life like they
have problems relating to them and then
you have these women who are represented
of the beauties and they are allowed to
cuss them do you not think that actually
allows these permits in their in their
bedrooms with their mum upstairs feeling
like i can do this to women as well so i
i actually understand a little bit like
how recruiting works and the thing is
again as i said in the beginning of the
podcast it's not a good pod
podcast if you don't bring on
opinionated people with a conflict of
ideas
so when when you're recruiting and i'll
say this like fresh and fit they're
they're women on their show are not
representative of all women and i know
this from recruiting
polarity yeah yeah but it's because like
when you're trying to have a battle of
ideas you want two people on the
extremes as much as you can like this
would be boring if if we all agree yeah
boring yeah like this is i agree this is
what we want but we can still have like
respectful dialogue right
yeah we have and like you guys have been
great guests like you've been super
respectful and you showed up on time
like you you did everything i could want
from a guest but sometimes
i'm telling oh god these these girls
these ladies
they'll interrupt you a million times
they'll show up late they'll like
they'll but they had a girl on the other
week when i when i was on it they had a
girl on and she was um
she had studied at an ivy league and she
was uh very liberal and she you know she
had a very feminist perspective and
everything like that and i don't i don't
i mean i don't know maybe i'm just you
know i don't know biased or whatever but
i i didn't see them treating her with
disrespect they allowed her to speak
they allowed her to make her points you
know she wasn't the architect i mean i
think she was probably she liked to go
out and party or whatever but she wasn't
that archetypal you know kind of fresh
and fit type girl really and um
yeah you know i so i i don't think
like you're presenting it like they're
just going for the you know the most
egregious examples of that sort of
stereotype and i don't really think that
they are and i i think they have them on
a lot
but i i i absolutely do get what you're
saying um
from my experience with myron like i
started a a youtube channel that i i
only do it part time
and
before i started i said to myron like
what do you think on this idea do you
think it's a good idea i knew it was
someone that was going to give me the
truth it was someone that was
i saw always modeling to to men and
women the truth of things so i thought
right okay i'm going to speak to him
and he was so respectful he said you
know do you have any more questions how
else can i help you like very different
to probably what you're seeing on on the
podcast right completely different
person really respectful checking in how
you doing what's happening
and
yeah i would just say that he did say
things to me like you know how old are
you
and i was really concerned because you
know i'm not a young creator and i
thought that's going to hold me back and
he was like telling me the ways that i
could maybe get around that
and my my my experience
of him was nothing but like respectful
yeah because what they're doing is
they're
a lot of these guys that watch this show
they do come for the red meat
but the genius of fresh and fit the
genius of walt the the genius of myron
is that they're selling these guys what
they want
but the undertone message is giving them
what they need bang
and you have to understand for the guy
that's in indiana and he's 18 and he's
probably a bit immature and he likes to
see the drama
he's seeing that
but when he goes to let's say he gets
married let's say he actually gets
married
when he goes and he watches fresh and
fit he learns about hypergamy and female
nature which is one of the which is the
untold pillar that a man needs to have
in his life on top of normal
competencies
what malt what walt and myron are doing
is with extremism showing that young man
in that flyover state in america
what to look for in that woman he
marries in indiana and how to make her
stay happy and how to keep the frame
with her because he understands female
nature now are they doing it with big
glaring red flags and fireworks and and
wwf wrestling yes but without that
they will not tune in and for that
reason they cannot save those young guys
lives and
i argue and i really mean this not only
are they saving the young man's life
they're saving the woman's life and
they're saving the life of those
children amen but i would say the same
even for like people like pearl right
pearls of a female creator you know
she's not agreeing with everyone she
says the truth like when i first said
when i first saw pounds and i say when i
logged into your live chat and i said
paul you just don't care like there's a
certain entertainment to that but like
from getting to know pal she's a good
person like it
what you see isn't always like and as an
entertainer you just come at it at like
a different
angle because you have to be more
extreme in order to get the message out
or people won't watch like like for
example what was the title of this show
ladies let your man cheat because i want
because i want people to click on it now
we get all of that
but i'm not even gonna like i don't want
to date a guy that's cheating don't you
know no offense
it's an attention economy what we live
in yeah i get all of that and i get
everything that you guys are saying i
think you're negating though the
social responsibilities because you're
like it's saving these men and these
women and these kids but also what does
it say to
how men actually respect women i would i
would say
that there is a lot to go against that
framework with
the man can do what he wants and the
woman must comply to that the man
can sleep with lots of other women but
but you can't sleep with men like this
inequality
i think that's actually like detrimental
to just us having a modern society just
being respectful of each other but their
standpoints are so immature um
and and it comes up whenever they're
with somebody who is actually in a
relationship and they speak to them and
it's like it doesn't measure up because
it's really immature it doesn't measure
up in the world real world so you're
you're you're putting yourself in the
framework as a coach but what you're
teaching people is actually really false
because how do they sustain a
relationship you may get a girl you may
be able to mack her and get her but how
are you sustaining that it's not going
to be missing on the money mondays in
the fitness show yes so if you if you
money and and fitness yeah so they're
teaching the money in the fitness and
the style and and the frame and the
frame really comes from the
understanding of how
female nature is how what what will
drive a woman to do certain things what
keeps her happy money and fitness no no
okay it's the third pillar it's the
undertone so there's all the red meat
there's all the the cussing and the
swearing and the things that draw people
in but the undertone message is teaching
female nature another reason that rolos
they're wrong
but they're not wrong they literally
aren't the castle
you can disagree with it how do you
think how do you think that they're
wrong i think that they're wrong because
it's unrealistic to place yourself as um
i i'm i'm allowed to do whatever i want
and you must comply but because
but
that's just not like because let me tell
you what they're not able to do be
average not produce not create a life
for a woman where she feels like it's
the best life she could possibly live
because in the event he does not do
those things she is [ __ ] gone she
didn't even get her in the first place
yeah i think i think most red pill
content creators agree with me when i
say leave the bombs if your dude's not
we're like refuses to work like leave
him i agree with him that is the point
that is yeah like say if you like
if your partner had lost like their job
or some money for like six months i
would still stand by them oh yeah sure
that's what i'm saying that but that's
the reality of life like literally some
people may fall on if you're committing
to somebody you're committing to them in
their good and bad times yeah so if it's
always why would you want
i wouldn't want a partner to have that
pressure on them that i always have to
be the boss i always have to be
providing
you that's a lot of pressure you don't
put up not one i like a little bit of
pressure in your relationship no it's
not that it's it it's like
you know a limp dick it's not that
literally i don't want you
to have this that i always have to be
the alpha the the one that is doing
everything i don't as a human human to
human i don't want them to have that
pressure what i'm saying i don't want a
heart attack
like in your relationship do you
would you not just not be attracted to
your husband anymore if you felt that
like i could just take my foot off the
gas i've done that numerous times but so
has he with what though
work career my business is not going to
be interested in that in you i'm talking
about like how do you know
because i know because i feel i know
because he's going to be interested in
like you know you being a mom
are you presenting
exactly you present yourself well and i
have a business yeah but if you were
just like and we can work together yeah
i understand that but if you were to
just say like that's it like you're just
gonna look after the kids i'm gonna take
my foot off the gas with that i'm just
gonna go and hang out with the girls all
those things i'm not gonna do my hair
anymore you have great hair i'm not
gonna do my makeup anymore and i'm just
going to do what i want to do but but
that wouldn't be me being me
okay to do that and and those are the
things where i'm like actually what
about the person the human inside but we
should be with men that want to work and
be better yeah like
yeah so so
we shouldn't be dating guys that
wouldn't want to work no it's not that
as i said not dick it's not that it's
just if life is getting too much for you
yeah and you're with a partner you
should be able to speak to them yeah i
may need a month out are you saying this
from the guy's point of view yeah i
should be able to yeah yeah i agree and
that's so you don't have to be this
steam train that keeps on going and
let's keep on preparing
that's a sign of a good woman yeah
completely yeah i totally agree so why
are they not talking about that because
you're kind of talking about extremism
in a way
that is extremism yeah face the fact the
burden of performance is on men yes okay
your gut knows even when you pick the
guy
whether this is a month off or this
guy's a lazy [ __ ] there's a huge
difference your gut you know yeah you
know yeah so you staying with him for a
month are you really that [ __ ]
awesome no you know in your gut you got
a good one so you keep them yeah because
if you thought he was trash you would
leave his ass the burden of performance
is on men and that's what's so beautiful
about it because it goes back to the
hero thing i don't want a woman i can't
save that's [ __ ] boring it's men's
like it's in men
that's so bad but it's because women are
so wonderful you don't want to go that
way you know
why i think that's why
i is that what you thought for a reason
yeah
but i mean
that man that has that savior complex in
them like i'm going to keep on saving
don't you think you're always going to
buck up on the damsel you're always
going to back up on the person
you're going to meet up with
energy-wise you are going to meet that
woman that is always in distress and
then after a while you're going to be
like forever saving this chick and and
then she also is going to go to a space
where she doesn't want to be saved it's
not either it's such a toxic
relationship to be like i am always
going to be the knight in shining armor
it's it's it just doesn't work i don't
think it really works like i mean just
speaking for myself i don't think i go
into it looking i want to meet this girl
to save her i think it's you meet the
girl you're attracted to her for
whatever reason you know you're just
attracted you guys get together you get
on and then the desire to protect comes
out now protection and saving is right i
think i think justin isn't i think you
different cultures you're kind of
misinterpreting each other a little bit
like he's not literally talking about
saving yeah like oh this girl's a heroin
addict i'm going to get over no it
doesn't even have to be
i'm saying about providing yeah he's
talking about providing i would say
security is very different
provision and security yeah is this man
gonna protect me right protect our house
our kids that kind of stuff and provide
for them
i think that's that's masculinity that's
cool and i would also say that's what
gives a man the fulfillment in the
relationship absolutely nothing feels
better than being that guy
that i mean that's the wonderful part of
love but you know you just get the same
thing with it with children i'm sure
yeah the way you were making it sound
was almost like
the uh you know we are told that's the
main objective we are targeting women
who are sort of like broken women
because i
because they go into i am the savior
yeah because weak men are and so you
will attract somebody who is always in
perpetual drama and then after a while
they don't like you anymore because
you're always there with the solution
yeah and they're not after a solution
because they're in that cycle of drama
and then you're also trying to save her
all the time that's a terrible
relationship they're trying to teach
those to avoid those women yeah i'm not
disagree that dynamic doesn't happen a
lot it 100 does but what i'm saying is
that the desire to protect will come
about anyway it's not that i am
targeting like say broken women it's
just when love's there yeah when love is
there and that's what makes it love for
a man
and
picking a broken woman is really most
often
just a mating strategy for a weak man
bingo
the weak man can't hunt the healthy
amazing top level woman he's like that
[ __ ] is limping i'll go after her it's
easy pickings i agree because he's not
strong enough not fast enough to
actually get
that woman
that is up here this kind of woman i
have no i completely respect one i got
no beef women smart intelligent funny
they make life amazing
i do think men and women are absolutely
different and the problem that we're
having the reason those statistics are
the way they are
is because we're trying to fit men and
women in the same box when it's really
more of a yin and yang you can't live
without one another complimentary you
know yeah i'm i'm gonna read some super
chats um
ish do you remember the last super chat
i read by chance
uh it was like something about stds
because i went around no it was after
that oh let's see oh i think it was
sandra's yeah yeah okay
um okay sandra saw
i'm sorry guys i always butcher you
guys's name and i'm i'm gonna apologize
um sandra solomon um kevin samuels also
claimed to be a christian but he said hi
valuement she i wonder how the hell that
conversation went with god um
then you hadn't read the bible
okay that's so that's all there's a lot
of votes i gotta get through the super
chats um osmosis reacts we get it move
on please um
just lol uh the red pill community has
been infiltrated by polygamy pushers
trying to convince all men they are high
value and that they should be cheaters
question for pearl i love your content i
know you mentioned your dad was a top
one percent what was your family's
experience with infidelity if at all my
dad doesn't cheat and i know no one in
the manosphere believes me but my dad is
actually like the best person i've ever
met he doesn't drink he doesn't have
social media he doesn't cheat he's
actually like
like literally a great person um so
that's my answer to that sarah garvey
hey pearl let them know our show is
coming soon um sandra solomine if your
daughter comes to you broken because her
man cheated on her your first instinct
as a father is going to be to protect
her that's when you're gonna gonna
figure out that cheating on your woman
isn't okay
um okay
john 40 40. if matt had game like mr
licario says women love you for you even
when you're broken not only for your
money if he even if he's a rich simp
they'll end up like will smith
alberto nando retro i called bs on
andrew heard's story from day one depp
wouldn't swat a muskego a mosquito if i
bit him
sandra solomime
women need to stop throwing their cats
everywhere if women locked it down more
it limits man's options women should
stop being complicit dragon stalin
stallion
one zero zero one lady in the blue the
fresh and fit show is for men and women
and women take in the information
differently don't get upset at the
message because you disagree with the
delivery
albert
retro i in defense of men in general
there's plenty of women out there who
are plenty disrespectful to us treat us
like sperm banks and a in an atm get
your own gender in order before you tell
us how to behave um sandra solomon if a
woman wants to be comfortable with a
non-cheater do you think it'd be more
beneficial to look at the financial
decisions
making versus how much they make um av
myron is an a-whole older brother that
loves you enough to tell you the
uncomfortable truths that dramatically
improve your life on um honest citizen
does endorsing monogamy
um make someone blue pale roll it to
mossy donovan sharp think before you
sleep tyler the fiend all endorsed
monogamy stefan um pierre jerome f fresh
and fit always return energy that is
given and they also show how to be stern
and direct with women um if they were to
respond in soft voices and gentle tones
they would not be able to control the
show
okay is that okay can i ask you a
question
yeah for sure
i noticed that you said you're you're
talking about your father and i'm sure
he's an amazing man
but every time you said
he doesn't drink he doesn't cheat
you said he's such a wonderful person
i would argue
that
if i'm honest enough to tell the truth
and i support
the other half and i kill myself trying
to make her life wonderful then i also
am an amazing person yeah and so you
weren't a good person no i'm just saying
just for because of contrast sake i'm
not upset about it okay look i get
called a piece of [ __ ] all the time so
no it's fine i mean yeah yeehaw
but what i what i am saying is like
being a good person
and being monogamous are two different
things
your father
and rolo tomasi
and donovan sharp
are a product of a zeitgeist that is
about let's say 20 30 years back
and that's where everybody came up and
believed and lived and died by the sword
of the bible mostly
that monogamy was only way if your
father being a one percenter
or rolo or donovan
were 35 now here now in 2022 with
instagram and women blowing their phone
up all day i argue
that the likelihood of them being
monogamous for 25 30 years is
substantially less
not because
they're weaker not because of anything
other than
each generation faces a new set of
problems
and those gentlemen including your
father and respect
don't or never did had to face the
problems that let's say the gentlemen of
today have to
face when it comes to temptation against
the natural nature of biology as a human
being
i also think it's again as i've said the
situations you choose to put yourself in
so again including the year you're born
in in the culture
no but i like because you're not
relevant if you're not on social media
right now
you're not relevant yeah like so like in
business if you're trying to like build
yourself up in business linkedin
facebook like a lot of our business card
is on our instagram how people perceive
us treat us and allow us to have
opportunity in the market yeah but you
have to understand like this is a very
different industry than what my dad does
he's fine without social media i get
metal building deals because of
instagram okay
i'm just saying i'm just saying like
like
your dad yeah he sounds like a superhero
because even he is one percent from his
time
right
but i think there's it's important that
somebody watching this
understands the distinction respectfully
the distinction between what your father
chose to do with his life and being a
good person well i just when i hear that
someone chooses to be loyal like to be
entered into a monogamous relationship
with the woman that gave him seven
biological kids three adopted and
chooses to be monogamous i just have a
different level of respect for it i just
i then than someone that chooses to like
exercise their options do you understand
that most monogamous monogamous men are
not loyal let me tell you why
the evidence doesn't really support that
if you take surveys but i think usually
the red pill is like like they're just
lying but let's talk about let's talk
about
let's talk about loyalty though okay
because most men that get married
use
marriage and monogamy as a mating
strategy to get that woman
okay so he's trading sexual exclusivity
for
and marriage
for sex
but he makes vows
that he's going to do his best to create
the most wonderful life he can for that
woman they exchange vows
and in my opinion a man's loyalty is
keeping that second part
when most men don't they come home they
pop open a beer they smoke a bowl of
weed they watch a ball game they turn on
the xbox
okay
as they do that they do not produce and
provide for their woman and i would
argue that is the most unloyal man that
you can possibly come in contact with
because he stood in front of people and
made vows to take care of her provide
for her and create an amazing life for
her and he came home and popped open a
bud light that's not loyalty no i i
agree with you i i do like i always say
i think cheating is different for men
and for women i always say i i would
leave someone if they cheated unless we
had kids because if you have kids it's
not about you anymore but
i i just think it's cool like i just
respect my dad a lot for having the
option to do what he does and still
choosing to remain loyal to my mom and i
know the red pill will say forever oh
he's cheating he's cheating but but i
don't know my dad is just i respect him
a lot and i think it's really cool that
he does that i think there's a good
chance that there's a relationship that
your mother and your father have between
them that you'll never know about i'm
not saying he's cheating
but
if he did cheat
he's a damn good man from hiding it from
all of you so he can continue to paint
that picture of reality now me
i'm not going to do that because i would
rather live in truth
but if you know how they say if a tree
falls in the woods and nobody hears it
did it happen
maybe that zeitgeist that group of men
in that age range that was their
strategy now that we're in 2022
the strategy i think that it makes you
the best man shows the most character is
to just tell the truth okay just tell
the truth and don't embarrass your woman
i i agree with you but i i just don't
like the argument that like
ever because it doesn't feel good to you
no it's not that it doesn't feel good
it's that you'll believe what you
believe regardless of any evidence to
the contrary so if the evidence says
that one out of four men cheat you'll
say oh they all
i would argue and it's like if i say no
my dad doesn't cheat he doesn't do that
you say well he probably has an
arrangement with your mom behind the
scenes because i'm not saying that i'm
not saying that i'm saying there's a
chance you you just you just implied
that which is fine like i understand
that's your worldview but i just grew up
around like
i would say like the men of value versus
high value men which is just like the
type of men that kind of get their money
get their woman go buy a piece of land
and don't want to talk to anybody and
it's just a very different like world
than the like one that you guys live in
and that's partially what brought me
into the red pill because i was like
this is what you think high value men
are like right and that's kind of what
i'm arguing yeah because because you're
just you're putting
certain life choices
with value as a person and i'm simply
saying what created value in his time
and certainly in your life because
obviously you've turned out very very
well
him being valuable in that time and him
having that good impact on you is
incredible i'm just simply arguing
that
a man that in 2022 that tells the truth
takes care of his business takes care of
his family shows up for his wife in the
most important ways providing truly
loving her making sure that her life is
a [ __ ] carpet ride and then loving
the [ __ ] out of the kids and supporting
and doing the right thing that a man
should do because a man does have the
burden of performance and i put that
burden of performance
right there in the loyalty spot
in the turning up for your family that
is a good man
not whether you had sex with another
woman or whatever you know it's the
lying
it's the deceit that hurts so badly
and the reason that women are unhappy
is because the formula for happiness is
the gap between expectation and reality
yeah your father gave that to your
mother that's what made him a good man
for me i would rather not lie because
the world has changed since your father
was a father and from when i will be a
father so i'm going to be brave enough
old enough to love and be impactful
enough to tell the truth and you can
leave if you want
but if you leave me for a man you love
lest when i told you the truth you have
to respect that i tell you the truth and
then i back up what i said and that
loyalty is producing performing
providing and being who you say you are
but she might not want to know like that
stuff
i think that once just like your
situation i think if it's said once it
never has to be said again as long as
you respect it enough not to try to dig
poke pry
well just so just justin could i sure
yeah i could ask questions so so you you
wouldn't then subscribe to the sort of
keeping an unspoken kind of fight
because obviously you present because
you present obviously very high value
guy you're you're obviously gonna
present to somebody who's got
right options and the ability to do this
when you're with a woman so do you even
need to have that conversation i think
it's unethical not to have the
conversation at least once
cool what i mean like is it a situation
where like she would already know in
your course or you would just say
straight away this is
this is what i want to be doing into the
relate i think that i think that you
need to give a woman the opportunity to
really get to know you as a human and as
a person before you
have that conversation and the reason is
is a lot of women will stop seeing a man
they could have loved that could have
went right because of this subject yeah
but look at your relationship right and
i mean this with complete respect
there's a gap between you and him
you you were talking about it earlier
you know that he's seeing other women
that's creating that's creating distance
between you
when you could just talk about it one
time i didn't say i know that he is i
don't know you said that you have
probably
yeah there's there's a high chance right
there's a really high chance but
i
i
i
it just hurts too much to even like
bring that up then write him a note do
something because i'm telling you what
you're costing yourself
is if he feels guilt about it and i
promise you he does especially in the
western world
then what's happening is he's only
loving you to a certain degree
and he's protecting himself because he's
worried that if he gets caught you're
gonna leave but if you could just
snap that and let him know that you
already know because you clearly already
know
if you could just let him have that you
would be shocked at how much more
capacity to love you he would have
because he would be able to trust that
he can love you fully yeah can i forget
that but it's just you know you get it
but it doesn't feel good you're scared
of it yeah it doesn't yeah then do it
then
then be that bold and fix it it doesn't
feel good and you have given me
something to think about for sure but
for my situation like we're talking
about parents like my dad was so much
like paul's dad um yeah my dad actually
looks like you
did
my dad
my dad isn't a hero
but you know my parents my my parents
are no longer here like i'm not i'm not
a girl with a big business i don't earn
a lot of money
like
this like my situation is different
where like he provides everything for me
i'm lucky i don't want to
invite any kind of
just yeah it doesn't feel good and if
you
had if you had to bet money
on whether he's cheating or not cheating
what would you put your money on and i
have a follow-up question about that
life or death i think this is a bit much
no i don't think it no no i think it's
completely fair if you think dude i
don't think you have to answer
like i have a feeling because
i'm aware because i'm just aware that
the type of guy he is he's not he gets
attention from women everywhere we go
but he's a very very private person i
think that's what like helps the
situation because he's good it makes you
feel better because you think he's
private and you don't have to talk about
it
but if you had to bet you said three
times you think he is right
but why don't why do i have to bring
that up
because it's bothering you
it's bothering you and again i think
that if you guys took this
situation it's a wedge it's a wedge
because you know what's happening right
and i'm not trying to be ugly in fact if
anything i'm trying to be hopeful to you
no i can hear that like i'm not i'm not
trying to i'm not trying to make a point
i'm simply telling you i've experienced
this i've been with a girl that didn't
know
okay and i felt like i couldn't tell her
and because i felt like i couldn't tell
her
i would hold back like a piece of my
heart
because i was terrified that if i gave
her the whole thing and she caught me
then it would wreck me
and i'm telling you that's a that's a
wedge
and that you could stop did she ever
bring up with you did you have a child i
ended up sitting her down and telling
her
and she didn't leave
are you still with her are you still
with her wouldn't you like to know
oh no
sterling sterling do i no no no way you
know what to help you hold on hold on to
help you
yes i am and sterling knows her well
i've been with her for a while yes she's
madly in love with him yeah okay for a
long time she's the most amazing woman
but the thing is is that like it is i
understand that but she won't want to
talk about that stuff with you like i'm
not i even if yes she does like we joke
about it all the time like it's so
because but here's the thing that but
here but hear me out here i no i'm i'm
genuinely trying to help you like you're
obviously a sweetheart we've been
talking to instagram for what six months
about going on your show
like what bothers me about this for you
is like when you're you're scared
is what you're what's happening you're
scared but just like jumping out of an
airplane or doing a big business deal
the more times you touch it the less
thing it is going to have to you yeah
but i don't want to sit there i know you
i know you don't want to but
unfortunately it's a rock in your shoe
which is a rock in the relationship and
it's stopping you and him
from going to this place where you don't
talk about something that's super
uncomfortable to getting to like here
but is it though because i just i just
feel i don't want like you're sitting
there saying you you sit there with your
with your partner and you talk about
these things and you laugh about it i
wouldn't be laughing about it okay no no
i i don't think you will and neither
were we in fact there there was a time
where
every time i've told a girl this they
leave for like a week
and what they really do is go
compartmentalize it and really unpack it
and really try to make their mind up
and what what i'm telling you is
is if you and him were able to have that
understanding and not speak of it
anymore and you released that guilt or
that burden and that fear of losing you
from him
you would get closer
and i think you would be likely to never
lose him because of it because very few
women can see the world for how it
actually is do you like it no do you
want a man that's going to cheat on you
no
will you accept it you're already
accepting it so why not take the
benefit of getting the information
that's going to make your love deeper
because what you're really not accepting
is him as a man because men are this way
and i don't say that to make a point i
say it because it's true he wants to
love you more
he can't because he's scared of what
he's going to lose if you see who he
really is and he can't bring the truth
to you
tell them
i i just feel that everything is is fine
with us
how it is like
it's amazing you're scared
you're scared it's not amazing because
you're scared he's cheating on you or
you don't like that feeling in your gut
because you don't want to give him full
permission because maybe somewhere he's
not he is you already know you've said
it four or five times maybe i don't know
so why don't you watch your position by
having the conversation with him and let
him know that you love him so much
you're not gonna leave okay
for example if i had that conversation
with him he might put a ring on your
finger and he no but and he wasn't there
and he wasn't doing that that's
basically giving him a card to go yeah
i'm just gonna he's gonna do it anyway
the difference is is he going to love
you at 110 percent or is he going to
love you at 75. i'm not sure it is
absolutely no not true absolutely back
to your world view though yeah like
that's like the red world's just your
opinion because it doesn't mean anything
like think of their relationship yeah
well sterling sterling i mean do you
disagree with me about what what about
what i thought i thought that whole
spiel was the biggest manipulation i
think i'd seen in my face in a very long
time
where were your feelings there was no
time it was all if you tell him and it
was the subtlety in your voice and i was
like wow this guy's good but it's the
baritones in your voice
if you tell him
that you understand
he'll open his heart up to you yeah it's
true and i was literally watching your
eyes and i was i was like it's not true
it is true because where's your feelings
in this if you're already feeling that
gut
that gut wrenching that that's actually
really powerful and it's actually very
bad for your body that is sitting in
there that's one thing that he's saying
that is actually accurate to have the
conversation
but it's not for him to then be like oh
my god she's the one she's understanding
it's actually to is is to create a bond
with you that i'm feeling something like
we're not all together there and is
there another woman involved in this and
then you take the power it's not to say
i'm okay if you have others because
you're a high-value man and i've
adjusted
that justin's point will be that um
he explained his point just literally
it's just what about her feelings every
every every guy ultimately is gonna
behave in this manner
i think like you guys i agree i feel
like you've got that one
view though like that's that's like
well
because because and here's the thing
like my one criticism of red pill is
like
is that you guys will always say like
it's facts like we should believe the
facts fidelity is old as marriage
what infidelity is as old as marriage
yeah it is a hundred percent like
predominantly men no i agree with you
i'm not disagreeing but i'm saying like
if if surveys are telling you that 25 of
men cheat right and let's let's up it
and say it's 50 let's say half of them
like another i think i think it's less
than 25. you think it's less than 20.
okay yeah because i think 85 want to
and only about 10 can yeah well and if
you if you if you take well if if let's
go to the income category you take men
that make over 250 thousand dollars a
year like it ups to 50 from 25 to 50
percent of those i think fitness will
allow you cheat more than uh money
all right super ripped
i don't know
more than that
it's just it seems like like the red
pill guys it's just no matter what
they're cheating they're cheating all
the time but to be fair to be fed
regardless of any like data that's put
in front of them but but she has
identified her man as being a very high
value guy who who would have the ability
so he's already in that category isn't
it exactly it i know that he has the
ability he's already in that category of
the guy who would
completely be absolutely i know how many
like when we go out how many women are
like looking at him it's like it's not
the guys looking at me it's the women
and i i sit there and i watch that
that's what makes me know yes he has got
the ability to cheat and yes i will
admit yeah in a way it does make him
more attractive but it doesn't i don't
think
i totally hear what you're saying and i
understand how you're trying to help me
but i just
don't think that sitting there having a
conversation going here's your your
green card from me i think he'd actually
like might even lose respect for me i i
i think that is a high possibility i
would respect you more because you
understand how the world actually works
i really like you may have that view but
i think that you you know your man
exactly and you know what that feeling
is and it probably does need to be a
conversation but to give him that kind
of pass and he's going to fall more in
love with you and unlock this chamber of
his heart that he has fastened away and
it's all going to open up and
no you know what you know what i think i
just don't think that's reality i i
think the reason why you deal with it
one of them you want to deal with it
that's that's my thing you don't have to
sit down and have that conversation if
this is what you choose you don't have
to sit down and have that conversation
that is your choice can i can i can i
make one point and i love justin i think
justin's absolutely bang on with with
with most of what he's saying but there
is one small point that concerns me and
justin and that is that if you get a
girl who feels like she's too much of a
pushover basically i i've lost
attraction for women not because they've
sat me down and had a conversation said
i don't care if you cheat but i've lost
sort of desire for women if i felt that
they were too there for me do you know
what i mean if they don't hold anything
back you know you think she's there i've
got her on to the next one do you know
what i mean
he knows that already with me he knows
that i'm there one hundred percent okay
wow if i if i push that like more like
we're just just if that like
but don't you think don't you think we
all have that desire to chase for the
sort of the other the unattainable to
some extent i mean when when a woman is
sort of
somewhat she holds something back that
seems to me to increase the desire when
there's a girl she's just like
completely all over me
i just sort of
i can sometimes lose interest a little
bit but i think the only thing i would
say is it depends in what stage you are
if i was looking for a serious right
this is going to be the woman yeah i'm
going to say i think that trying to be a
hero thing is is so important and always
be doing this because what gets me
excited about being in this my
particular relationship is i get so
excited about going out and
slaying dragons and hunting and coming
back home be like look how i've leveled
it up again i've leveled it up again
again again again and that's my
responsibility so i get really happy
when i feel like i'm doing a good job
for her in that way
i think a large reason why you think
that a man
would lose respect for you
if you allowed him to go out and cheat
is because if we flipped that scenario
on its head
and you were with a guy
and he said hey baby
go out and
climb on as many dicks as you want you
would lose respect for him
church and i think that you are
interpreting this
through your personal
female lens
whereas it's a very different
perspective
could be yeah but i don't think um
i just think some people actually who
sign up for monogamy are fully fledged
this is what i want and i don't
subscribe to the thing that all men are
going to cheat i think there are some
people it comes apart of their loyalty
their integrity their morality it's all
tied in and they are not they're not
going to be like oh this is okay
even to bring it up it's just like no i
don't want to do that it's not okay and
then they're going to start second
guessing so what's this one on i just
don't think it's as clear-cut as you're
making it out i think all men i don't i
kind of i do agree and disagree that i
think i don't think that all men want to
cheat
because i think most men feel guilty
about the idea of cheating on the act
just the pure idea of it they have guilt
associated with it
and so they don't it's not because they
don't have the lust the lust is still
yeah we said that i think that goes for
everybody right
lots of us want stuff and we are never
ever going to get it i don't think women
say i'm saying i think women have like
that we're hypergamous so it's i don't
want to say it's the same thing because
you're right men have a higher sex drive
than women but like women
always want the next best thing like the
next best guy
what but that is still one guy
not everything oh sure yeah yeah
but i'm saying there's always going to
be a better guy
what we don't we don't want anyone else
when we're in a relationship with that
guy we have absolutely
zero
interest that's why we're doing
instagram i think it also goes back to
the idea that
women do the monkey branch team where
they hold on to one and they swing onto
another whereas men if they could they
would hold as many branches absolutely
as they could they would octopus exactly
but is that all is that as just sexual
partners or is it yeah
it's just sexual partners it's the idea
that women will always want to stick to
one man so they will monkey branch
knowing that they will end up with the
highest valuable man they want
men it goes back to the point of the
title of the today's message
men
or women cheat however men would
exercise options most men don't have the
opportunity or the ability
to cheat if they had the ability to it
would be an option to do so they know
that as a high-value man most men that
are able to cheat would be high-value
men
they have options and the woman that is
coming to their side
will have to understand that this is who
they are this is how the world works i'm
in high demand if i can give you
a certain level certain lifestyle
and in return this is what i expect love
included love including love included
yeah and i think like if you want to do
that i mean i
i get it like if a one percent guy if
you've gone through all the work to get
to where you are and you can do that and
that's what you want to do i don't like
i'm never going to shame a guy for
wanting to do that
right but i think but going back to what
you were saying about paul's dad because
paul's very much like my father
is i do kind of get what justin's saying
there with if our dads
were
their age
now
with
having options of women all over the
world not just like in our towns
i think things could have been like it's
also not just it's been different it's
also not just his options
it's the options that all the women he's
interacting with have
that changes the game entirely yeah
because he's not the only one the
options every single woman with an
instagram account has options well
guarantee if anyone any woman in this
room opens up their dms and we go for
that message requests i guarantee no no
i guarantee
there's dudes who are like oh you're
beautiful there's always there's always
guys hovering always yeah yeah there's
always that orders but they're playing
by the old they're reading the as ryder
massey would say the old set of books
you know that there was there was the
old rule book was like justin said
monogamy you know it was societally
enforced it was enforced with with shame
and to some extent with religion
although the influence of religion has
receded you know over the last century
but you know we're now in this sort of
we're now in cardi b world aren't we
where it's like everything's out the
window do you know what i mean like
anything goes now there is no societal
really shaming about anything really
and therefore what justin is saying
makes is is correct because it's
actually in that environment it's
actually better to be honest and just
own it and just say look i'm a guy the
reality is you know biologically we want
to spread our seed that's my program
however i love you you're my main goal
it's the deceit that bothers people and
that's yeah that's my problem and that's
why i respectfully because i mean you
have something that many many people
don't have in a 20-year marriage i super
respect that
i would also say it's probably psychics
i didn't catch your age how old are you
41 i'm going to be fine next week yeah
so but but it's not
okay the majority of my friends are in
the same position okay
and respectfully the reason i i don't
think that i'm trying to be manipulated
number one i got no skin in the game but
number two it is very glaringly obvious
that there is this wedge between you
that's being unspoken
and you've also said because of who he
is as a man and that you know that he's
probably doing it
you still are not gonna leave so if he's
gonna do it and you're not gonna leave
why are you torturing yourself and not
just ripping the band-aid off
and
giving the communication part of your
relationship an opportunity because i
promise you if you if you address it
every at least once maybe twice maybe
three times however many it takes that
feeling will go away
because you have already addressed it
you have uncovered that you've cut the
lights on the boogeyman's not there
anymore you know he's doing it and you
know you're not gonna leave so why why
suffer
why i don't understand i'm not trying to
manipulate her i'm not trying to look
because you know
i got no skin honest i would yeah
exactly i i would suffer like for
if it was okay i'm gonna give you two
scenarios if it wasn't happening
then that's basically giving a pass to
him that i'm still gonna be here if you
go and do that okay that's if it's not
happening if it is happening
for me that is more pain
would be to have that conversation
because then she knows like but there's
and then it's just yeah it makes it real
more pain happens while people are
thinking about things
then i i i think i think that's a
different question
and that's why it could be one
conversation hey i know you're probably
doing this i love you i'll never leave
you okay people i don't know what it is
i
like what i'm saying to you that kind of
underlying anxiety all the time you guys
in red pearl talk about it all the time
like competition anxiety i'm always you
know in a salon i'm always trying to get
things done i'm always trying you know
it's constant and i keep doing that i
keep doing that to kind of
feel better in myself but it's mainly
for him are you gonna are you gonna quit
doing that if you found out he's not
cheating
if i found out yeah no i would never
quit i would never quit doing it no way
but if he
was doing it
it wouldn't be that do you know what i
mean it's that that feeling like i'm
going to go get how does that happen
i'm going to have these injectables but
then if i knew he was if i knew he was
doing it i'd almost be there sitting
like
chopping the potato for dinner being
like
like
rather than like you know why am i i
would kind of feel this is
there'd be a reality that this is a
really hard life and he could leave at
any time i'd rather just
like all girls like to live in some kind
of even if it's a fantasy that's where
we like to be at all times
it's really hard to explain i've been
cheated on and i'm going to tell you my
life was a lot better before i knew
i was like
it's like i think that's the reality for
most people and that's why i was hearing
you and i'm like
yeah if she does this it is unhealthy
not to have the conversation but this is
what's so interesting is she is a woman
is telling you exactly how she feels in
a very cohesive clear way and you're
just saying it's something else it's
just not like then what is it so what
i'm hearing from a lot of you guys is
that you would much rather be lied to me
no no no no i think it it depends on the
person and what's at stake do you know
what i mean she's described her
relationship like he's a high value man
and she's a good man he's a good man
she's not earning that much do you know
me she's got a lot to lose if the
relationship doesn't go well that's her
situation that's her personal therefore
she needs to she needs to she needs to
weigh up her options so what he's saying
doesn't necessarily mean that's right
for her relationship it might be right
for someone else but not necessarily her
do you see what i mean that's not hard i
don't think you're wrong actually i
think it's true what hurts for me is i
hate i hate to see another human hurting
when you could just be honest and maybe
that's a man pragmatic type thing that's
less emotional so if that is the answer
for you and you you want this amount of
pain that you're going through is worth
not knowing the truth and and that's
better than knowing the truth the truth
because i've been in the situation as i
said before that i've been cheated on
and like and i've been in a situation
where a guy's been really upfront and
saying this is this is what it is do you
agree or disagree and stuff it doesn't
hurt any less
do you know what i mean it doesn't
actually hurt any less the act of that
happening to me wasn't do you know it
didn't make me feel oh like because he
told me i respect him more no it didn't
it just made me feel like oh [ __ ] i've
actually agreed to this and this is
what's happening [ __ ] like do not be
like it's just i was annoyed at myself
that
entered the relationship why are you
when when when he when he said this
was it it was at the beginning so i went
into it but it didn't hurt any less do
you see what i mean what did he say
though did he say i want to be
non-monogamous
i'm not gonna you know i'm gonna be yeah
playing around essentially
my brother had that my brother had this
the other day he he's he was dating this
girl they've met up quite a few times
and
she basically has turned around to him
and said look like you're rare i don't
mind waiting for you and he's just like
look like you know i am dating other
women she's gone oh i don't care like
you're right but i think that i
understand that because there isn't as
much like investment there straight away
do you know what i mean yeah
i think in the early days it's different
isn't it the early days is different
because you guys are still kind of
semi-independent or whatever well you're
not getting
me with change i think so it's very
clear
what's going on here
you're okay with it because of the value
exchange a lot of times women leave men
that cheat because he cheated and the
exchange of value
doesn't balance out
when she finds out he's cheating because
she was
taking some of the value of sexual
exclusivity into the equation but when a
man so far surpasses the value
the woman doesn't care and she stays
which is exactly what you're doing
because if a lesser man were cheating on
you you would leave his ass because men
have the valuable performance may not be
cheating
you literally may be being insecure and
you may be reading too much into
something
that's true
don't worry if he hasn't he hasn't and
he isn't right
it's becau that if he isn't and he's the
man you're saying he is right and he
isn't cheating on you it's because he
has some kind of
value
around he has some kind of guilt and
values around cheating right
i don't think that that kind of man
will cheat
even if you tell him he can
because he only has a hand
he would i don't think he would it's a
risk that's true actually yeah like
you're sitting there like i can fly
around the world i can do it i live in
shelton sorry i could live i live in
cambridge
and i can do whatever i want
and i ain't cheating on this lovely
woman
and then she's like oh you could cheat
on me
no he we wouldn't
like
he's gonna start now
yeah all of a sudden you're like oh i'm
gonna really tag me in whoa let's go i
don't think he's gonna do that
but he may lose respect
i don't
i don't think men lose respect like that
again i think i think he absolutely
could be like actually she's quite needy
maybe i'm good i don't think there's a
meridian of things that can go through
the man's mind that none of us know and
do you need to do that and i would just
say no there's a lot less things that go
through a man's mind mistaken
sex
we don't know this man as well and i
just think
it it doesn't need to be touched i kind
of feel as well that like the way that
he
does behave when there are women looking
at him and it's quite like i'm on it
obviously how does he behave
he just
doesn't even know he doesn't
even care he's just getting on the thing
and i think you're fine yeah that's what
i'm saying
he's probably like most men that would
act on it will hide it
but to be fair when he watches this
conversation yeah yeah yeah no your
relationship is fixed yeah you tell him
yeah yeah
yeah oh i went on a podcast tonight
trust me he'll watch every second of
this did you tell him you're coming on
tonight no he doesn't well he doesn't i
don't watch it
so he's so in his own
thing in his own world like the he's
naturally red pill without even knowing
he didn't even know what red pill it was
he just is who he how did you get
interested
how did you become interested in it then
was it just something that you found
when you were going online or it's it's
just something that for me since i was
really young since i was like 18 19 i
had clear
very very clear message that was given
to me in quite a harsh way okay um that
made me it was about my looks
right yeah when i was really really
young and i basically went from one day
like tuesday being the super super ugly
girl to the next day i i was
really really good looking when i was a
young girl
um and i got a very clear message of
sort of how things worked around that
and also just being a woman that has
only been with
guys that are of high value there's no
point to me to go and have attention
of
guys that
aren't going to give me what i want you
know you know how i was telling you that
that if i had a child or a daughter that
i would want to give her the harsh truth
of the world yeah what you learned was
the harsh truth of the world that beauty
is currency yeah it was it was i went
from one i went from
uh it literally i don't know what day it
was but it was like a tuesday and these
boys were like bullying me
um i had like this frizzy hair like i'm
i'm blind it's about without like
contacts and i had like these big
glasses on
and i just was an ugly 16 year old i
really wasn't like you know i was a
really great girl i was a good person i
was from a good home a good stable home
but i was aware
that
you know these guys were just horrible
to me they would like throw me in the
river and stuff
and then my girlfriend my girlfriend
yeah my girlfriends would like have to
like save me all the time
and then
there's this one guy that kind of liked
me and he was like teased by all his
friends for liking me and i remember
like how embarrassed i felt and then it
was literally the next day like me and
my dad were just out and about i think
we went to the opticians and they said
oh do you want to try these contact
lenses and i i wore the contact lenses
and i was really into like hair and
makeup and things like as well and i
didn't even think about that i just went
out like looking different and
it was a completely different response
i got from yeah all the guys like they
were no longer interested in the other
girls they were all interested in me
they all wanted to ask me out
and i i didn't really know how to handle
it to be honest but that's that was the
shift that that made me realize that
this is really important and nice paul
as you know like how many times have i
said oh i'm like insecure about the way
i look today and i am i will outrightly
admit that
but it's
i got the message very very young and
yeah it's just that's just it yeah and
so i would argue that as a parent
teaching your children
or as let's say young women are coming
up right now
eventually might get this message that
beauty is currency
and you can call it shallow you can call
it mean it cannot feel good but it is
absolute fact and truth
and men have to look in the eye of truth
and nature in the same way which is the
burden of performance
men value beauty and loyalty women
provide provision and high achievement
and status in men
and as bad as that sucks and as many
feelings as that hurts it's absolute
fact
and so instead of hiding from it or
putting feelings on top of it
really good people valuable people are
brave enough to tell the ugly truth and
brave enough to put things on the line
where people are going to hate them for
it but in the end they will save more
heartbreak than the ones that lied and
tried to put things over the top of the
way the world really is
that's true but my
my god kids i i don't have kids of my
own but my goddaughter to me
is the most beautiful girl inside and
out so i'm kind of have a bit more of a
blind view when it comes to that
that's the difference between a man
sleeping with a woman and a man being
able to fall in love with her
that beautiful on the inside thing yeah
yeah i get that but like what you were
saying about your pet about parents like
because attraction's real attraction
first and then a beautiful heart too
yeah that's what makes a main a main
chick right
instead instead of so if we're talking
trees and monkey branches the man if
he's got a good woman and she's
beautiful she could even be less
beautiful than some of the branches
but if she's got a good heart and a good
soul
and she's incredible on the inside it
won't be about the branches he'll make
her the whole [ __ ] trunk and the
roots
because it is hot it's hard to keep up
keeping trying to you know always look
good all the time all those things
that's hard like that's scary a big part
of it is just getting older
i would much rather a woman
who doesn't add
like like justin was saying
she could be very average looking
who doesn't add any
drama to my life that's not true
sterling she at least need to be an
eight
i'd rather take an eight that i love
being around than a ten
but
that's but the the less drama she adds
to my life the more valuable she is
right like because i want i want her to
be my peace
or i want to spend if i want to spend
time with a woman i genuinely want to
spend time with her then she has to be
somebody
who attracts that
she has to be peaceful towards me no not
none of this nagging [ __ ] not adding
drama to my life not nitpicking like no
just adding that peace and that love
that's the thing i think girls
like we we sort of don't always like i
didn't understand for a long time that
it's not all about looks because for
guys i i know it starts with looks but i
didn't realize that guys like will date
down and looks in order to get looks get
you in the door yeah
right right and i know peace keeps the
door open yeah sterling is absolutely
not lying because i have seen him
straight up kick out
dimes
that were horrible to be around these
women are [ __ ] tens and sterling's
like
and he's not mean to him it's not like a
fresh and fit exit it's more of a
listen
unfortunately it looks like we're not
going to be able to see each other any
longer um i'll call you an uber tristan
tate does like this i've seen sterling
do this to legitimate tens and that's
how it should be done i'm not about this
talking mean to women either but i think
that's the same that's the same with
with guys you could have a guy that
is like but but for us it's not always
like about
looks i guess but it's yeah because
it takes it it goes far from yeah
beautiful woman yes i'd rather a guy
who's like a seven of them masculine
rather than math the look there's a lack
of masculinity in men today yeah for
sure
i'm gonna read some super chats um
wow there is
the last one i think i did was
let's see
let me just read down until i've read it
before okay jc see chat bullying can be
positive um
nsu c surely men have more options than
you think
since men can just book escorts who will
be discreet more attractive than their
girl um these these sheilas need to
understand that men and women love
differently a man can sleep with other
women and love you just the same
integrity isn't an issue if he's honest
about things um man drake late to the
party there are also high status men who
get into relationships then
then women without any reason begin to
think they are cheating then the
constant hovering a need for reassurance
becomes near psychosis be easy every
every guy wants to cheat even if they
don't do it even if they watch corn
that's them thinking about cheating i
don't do it it doesn't mean it's a
massive the massive urge isn't there my
nature wants to hunt sandra solomon look
up cambridge university study of
polygamous wives it doesn't benefit
women at all the only person that
benefits is the man craig greaves pearl
is looking pretty today thank you craig
alberta albert retro would you please
stop calling these boys a red pill red
pill is about truth not being a dog who
says whatever he needs to get laid
justin's running dude
white noise
justin's running game on the dark-haired
lady right now she should get away asap
no
dude i'd love to see her relationship
work out yeah i just i just wanted to
check um
no game is being run no game is green
okay men are not naturally monogamous we
aren't designed to be reproductive since
the beginning of time only 38 percent of
men have procreated with the other 95 of
women women want to be with the best men
want to be with the most um
ryan reynolds spinning facts she calls
it manipulation and be upset but it
doesn't mean it'll change she wants high
value men to be like her and feel stop
and listen they're teaching high value
men you're a woman not a man sandra
solomon just because he it's honest
doesn't make it right leaders hold
themselves to the same standard that
they have that everyone that they hold
everyone else too dictators have a
different set of rules for themselves
black ops if women nowadays were virgins
at marriage then i'll condemn men
cheating women explore their options in
their 20s but most men can't can't do
that until their 30s which is why they
get married so fair game just l this is
sick trying to convince her and other
women to settle for marriage who they
can't have genuine one-on-one
relationships is sick and not good for
society honest citizen absolute morality
is not determined by changing
circumstance or culture
reframing that idea of love and loyalty
to suit polygamy only works and
with conditional morality just lmao this
is horrible advice telling young men to
adhere to these hedonistic feelings is
absurd and not good for society
oh okay and then that was all of them oh
we're hedonistic were there any at the
end
um okay okay cool who would have thought
they'd call the porn star hedonistic
class can i can i jump in
i want to read one um
there's two super chats i missed um alan
maxwell the dude in the blue shirt is so
full of cracks smooth talking steak
snake run away ladies
yeah he wants him to run away from me so
he can try to catch him
okay okay
natalya del del vale they five dollar
super chat and there's no message i
appreciate you guys
um just you guys know all super chats
are going to upgrades in the studio the
current upgrade we want is um a new
lighting system so that's a new thing we
want to buy so i really appreciate the
super chats we could not make the show
happen without them
um thank you so much ish did you have
something um no you said it oh okay you
were leaning again i thought you did
nailed it okay um
you said you wanted to yeah really
quickly this is this is a uh this is not
the original question i was going to ask
there's a different question i have
for the ladies here you're tearing the
studio apart yeah yeah it came for now
she just said all the super chats
[Laughter]
for the ladies quick quick question
do if your man watches porn do you
consider pouring corn starch corn he
watches corn hub
do you consider that cheating no no no
no
no i don't i don't i don't think he does
no okay okay but if he didn't if he did
no
sort of sort of okay okay
the two ladies at the back
no
and no
okay
why not he's lusting after another woman
this kind of makes the point that we've
been talking about all day
why in why why
they can they can get a relationship
okay but but possession it proves the
point of
that i was making before of
that lust is insatiable he's always
going to have it yeah
the only thing he's doing now is he's
fapping into a
like a tissue and he's like a [ __ ]
nerd instead watching me instead
instead of going out and talking to a
woman
which okay which would you
would would that hurt you more if he
went out to a bar
and didn't sleep with her but started
flirting with another woman would that
hurt you more yeah yeah yeah then hurt
more than what then him jumping into a
tissue of a point
because it's more risk of losing their
position
that's why yeah
i'd agree that's why
yeah because that woman could actually
convince him to take him it's not the
sexual act that bothers me i think
that's really obvious position
but it emphasizes the point is that we
all agree that everybody has lost like
literally yes and
they're gonna think about sex and so are
women and that goes back to me that's
all i was asking but are women
robbing one out to paul as much as dudes
nope nope have you got you you want to
know this are they okay you can explain
this in one sentence
who has ever heard of a lesbian bath
house
orgy
you've never heard of that you have
heard of gay bath house or juice though
right what's that
it's an orgy in a bath house but
that could sort of spa but the whole
point is that like
like even when humans are
gay by their
sexual proclivities
play out
so gay men
happiest men in the world
justin would know
he got me that's why he said his
compliment yeah
gay men are way more sexually
promiscuous than lesbian women are
way more i've never heard of that have
you ever heard of the phrase you hauling
no you holding is an american you've
probably heard of this as an american
you might have heard of this no you
hauling is an american phrase like you
whole is like a truck you rent to move
your furniture yeah right you hauling is
this thing that lesbians do where they
go on like one date
and the next day they move in together
that does not happen
with gay dudes i have heard of that this
is this is the the ex this is why like
it's actually very interesting to study
like
the relationships of
gay men and women
it's our nature's played out to the
extremes
yeah because gay dudes i mean the notch
counts on some gay dudes is is through
the roof you would know
another way
two
[Laughter]
when it's unfettered when the sexual
desire is unfettered by
basically women putting putting the
brakes on things so these dudes are just
like
gay gay dudes have basically no like my
uncle's gay i don't know so like the gay
dudes basically have no filter on the
sex stuff yeah they do have filters on
their relationships i agree but they
ain't got filters on the sex but
around if you're around lesbians they
always talk about oh this one's a player
this one does this it's the same type of
talk yeah but men aren't complaining
like that they just [ __ ] each other
totally there's no gossip they just [ __ ]
each other i was in l.a about three
weeks ago
one of my buddies
and he's actually gay okay
and he's like bro you wouldn't believe
he said dude start to finish and i mean
finish
i could get a [ __ ] in less than 30
minutes if i open the grinder out
okay yeah yeah like he's like start to
finish like meet guy
on on app meet guy in parking lot blow
job less than 30 minutes
women don't do that well they do well
well i think there are only only for you
i think there are many moments but
there's a lot i don't think there's a
culture there's not a great man on earth
that would bet
legitimate money that he could do that
with a woman but i'm telling you this
guy's like bro i bet you thousand
dollars i can do it okay i have another
really extreme example story so i used
to date this girl and she lived with a
gay dude and
he he broke up with his boyfriend
like the day before i came around to see
her
and like we were just chatting blah blah
and she was like yo like you won't
believe what the [ __ ] happened here last
night
he broke up with his boyfriend last
night and then that night he had five
penises in his butthole
within like less than 24 hours did you
say at the same time
at the same time
at the same time
that's what she that's what she was
saying
what you said
oh at the same time at the same time
but he gets to keep his born again
virgin card yeah not the [ __ ] oh my
gosh
okay um praise jesus that's a joke from
the previous episode yeah yeah we showed
them guys there's a reaction video
coming out this week um i felt like
these two over here just we're not
living a righteous life so i showed them
some chastity speakers now we're born
again
yes and i
i think they're changed men obviously
obviously
um okay but this anal sex only i'm gonna
i'm gonna
[Laughter]
um okay why don't we go around everyone
tell the people where they can find you
and any closing thoughts that you have
and then why don't you come back on and
you can do the same
like you can just go on and share mike
but yeah you start yeah well it's been
an awesome show and it's slightly
surprised the end to the show with the
the direction we took with the content
there
no it's been it's been great to to be on
and thanks paul for inviting me on uh
yeah so troy francis you can find me at
realtruckfrancis.com also my youtube
channel again it's troy francis talks
just search for that uh and on the other
socials uh instagram and twitter i'm at
uh real troy francis
i'm actually very impressed
with how cordial
this conversation went yeah like i've
been on fresh effect like nine times or
something like this wow
you yeah it
turns into
just ridiculousness very very quickly
and everyone here was so respectful you
know even though we disagreed yeah we
kind of we we do
kind of come to similar conclusions in
general it's the application of them
yeah the way we get there right
yeah ish
after the show we'll get you but
if anyone wants to see more of me uh
still in cooper.com
cornhub.com yeah
if anyone wants you to see a lot a lot
more
of me that's where you can go
only fans and i won't judge you you know
that's your thing it's throwing spot
holes on only fans
[Laughter]
so you can go to sterlingcooper.com you
can see that that's the main page to go
over my you can find all my stuff there
but if you're on youtube you can google
sterling cooper
s-t-i-r-l-i-n-g this has for my name you
find a ton of free advice around bedroom
stuff
all kinds of any issue any man could
ever possibly have in the bedroom
performance wise or pleasing or
partner-wise i teach you how to correct
that all for free on youtube go there
my instagram
cooper sterling my twitter is at
sterling wisdom thank you
tallulah johnson uh you can find me at
the feminine truth youtube channel
and uh yeah i only do the channel
part-time so i haven't got that much
content um i'm not sure what i'm doing
with the channel as yet
paul thank you so much for having me on
and
i much prefer being just a guest rob and
doing all this like myself so i've
learned a lot today thank you thank you
for coming
my name is justin waller you can find me
on youtube at jwaller7 i cover business
uh finance
basically everything that would make a
man better
you can find me on twitter at waller7j
instagram jwaller7 closing thoughts
um
first i want to say thanks to all the
ladies i feel like y'all are incredible
a special shout out to you because i
think what you've been able to achieve
is almost unheard of in this world and
it must say a lot about who you are as a
person and your ability to
relate and and go through the challenge
is that a relationship that long no
seriously i genuinely respect it and um
and
the final thought on that is
no matter what you do in your life and
no matter what your perception is i
think understanding and educating
yourself on how the world works
is the most
important thing that you can do so you
can take that information and go find
choice and i think you're a glaring
example
of a person that
very clearly has choice in their life
and so regardless of the fact that we
absolutely own polar ends of the
agreement i still respect it and i think
that that is what i would want for you
or or her in her relationship or my own
kids and myself regardless of the path
that you take so kudos to you on that
thank you yeah
i'm nana evans and you can find me and
my fellow co-hosts on
your aunties could never you can find us
on youtube and we go live on mondays and
you can find us on instagram as well
um yeah that's me
and i'm chad and yes as nana said your
aunties could never on all platforms
and then
hi i'm kristy gardman and pearl thank
you for having me it's my first podcast
so
that was a very good experience and
definitely
i've never
heard
guys saying what you guys said
maybe almost before
women here
so very fun and eye-opening experience
yeah thank you guys all for coming this
was a great show you guys were great
guests this was
fun
um okay so i have one last super chat um
from
a cyclone steve i don't know how you
guys come up with these names but
average gay men have 80 a year a
thousand in life that is crazy if that's
true
oh i think i think i just saw one more
that was real
all you're doing is getting an
opportunity what did you say again
average gay men have 80 a year a
thousand in life
i don't i don't know it's just a super
chat
and and the gracious goodness says shout
out to your aunts could never big up to
this pearly things or to the pearly
things okay
okay guys well thank you so much for
watching the show um don't forget to
like the video leave a comment and sign
up for memberships because the chat will
be going away in two weeks so sign up
for your memberships now so you can be
still leave comments and you know be
involved in the chat don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell and i will talk to you
guys next time bye
[Music]